bonjour je ne sais quoi
voilà françois legault qui est donc allé
rencontrer le lieutenant-gouverneur
michel doyon plus tôt ce matin il est
donc officiellement premier ministre du
québec avec moi pour cet après midi pour
suivre cette émission spéciale vous les
reconnaissez tout notre équipe de québec
sébastien bovet bien sûr martin biron
véronique presse et à l'est que
boissonneault hugo lavallée dans le
foyer
véronique je commence avec vous parce
que vous avez d'une certaine façon eu la
première entrevue avec le premier
monsieur legault en marchant après sa
petite rencontre avec le lieutenant
gouverneur oui effectivement patrice et
là je suis à l'entrée regarde on va tout
de suite allé voir m les prêts en un
client on verra ce que le premier
ministre décidera c'est vicky
prérogatives
alors on verra bonjour mais vous
remercie beaucoup
alors patrice ça met la table en fait
j'allais vous dire justement que je me
trouve à l'entrée du parlement pour
accueillir les députés et les futurs
ministres parce que il y en a pour
lesquelles on a obtenu la confirmation
on sait qu'ils vont être assermenté à
partir de 14h et qu'ils occuperont donc
des fonctions importantes au sein du
gouvernement
il a lu les voir arriver y en a certains
qui sont déjà arrivés mais vous allez en
voir d'autres arrivés au fur et à mesure
comme ça en dirait on va leur poser des
questions et je serai en mesure de vous
les présente très bien qu'on va écouter
tout de suite vous le voulez bien chacun
le premier ministre vous j'ai dit dans
ce corridor entre le bureau du
lieutenant-gouverneur et le parlement on
écoute pour rien tout dire que vous êtes
vous excité par ce tweet si votre
promesse de former un conseil paris vous
allez voir c'est tantôt ça a été un
exercice du taneja six de tenir tous mes
engagements
oui c'est très difficile on a beaucoup
beaucoup de débats compétents et c'est
un exercice qui dit si je le fais pour
le bien du québec
est ce que vous êtes satisfait de vos
choix est ce que vous croyez que les
gens que vous avez positionner dans des
ministères clés sont les bonnes
personnes
oui je pense qu'on va être capable
d'avoir un résultat d un gouvernement
qui livre des résultats pour le bien de
la population en se concentrant sur les
priorités sur lesquelles on s'est engagé
pendant la campagne électorale
donc le spac les québécois vont être
fiers de leur gouvernement
ces gens là vont avoir des défis majeurs
à relever vous avez une idée des défis
par exemple la laïcité de l'état les
seuils d'immigration c'est quand même
pas des dossiers simples à régler les
déjà dit à plusieurs plusieurs reprises
pendant campagne électorale nos trois
grandes priorités sont l'éducation
d'économies et la santé donc
évidemment il y aura d'autres dossiers
mais les trois grandes priorités
l'éducation l'économie la santé
merci tout le monde n'attend tôt c'est
très bien vernet que merci à vous pour
ce petit moment avec le premier ministre
bons réflexes
martin ce conseil des ministres on n'en
connaît pas mal les détails déjà il y
aura peut-être des surprises sûrement
comme à chaque fois dès hier déjà vous
aviez pas mal l'essentiel
revenons sur les grandes lignes simon
jolie barrette aura de lourdes
responsabilités sur ses épaules il a 31
ans et l'homme ça devient l'homme de
confiance de françois legault s'est en
fait il y aura un homme de confiance et
une femme de confiance et on remarque
des deux côtés que ce seront des jeunes
d'abord simon jaulin barrette 31 ans
sera responsable de l'immigration de la
laïcité et il sera également le leader
parlementaire du gouvernement donc un
poste extrêmement visible est important
et ses fonctions en occupant le poste de
l'immigration et de la laïcité
il va finalement remplir il va voir sous
sa coupole
les deux dossiers les plus délicats de
du gouvernement de monsieur legault
d'abord il doit revoir les seuils
d'immigration à la baisse ça veut dire
des discussions avec ottawa en
immigration
et pour ce qui est de la laïcité il
devra déposer un projet de loi pour en
ligne avec le rapport bouchard taylor
qui propose la recommandation de
d'interdire les signes religieux dans la
fpt dans les pertes des personnes en
position coercitive de l'état et ajoutez
également les enseignants alors il y
aura des négociations très importantes
avec les partis d'opposition
ce nobel à la justice sonia lebel à la
justice soient aussi vous
didier hier c'est madame lebel procureur
qui connaît bien les rouages la justice
assez mais on donne quand même âge les
barrettes le dossier de la laïcité donc
c'est donc dire qu'il aura comme vous
êtes beaucoup de responsabilités et vous
allez parler de l'autre pilier de madame
guilbaud qu'on voit entrer oui madame
geneviève guilbeault qui est la député
de louis-hébert il faut le dire parce
que c'est un peu le point de bascule ce
qui a donné l'élan à monsieur legault et
qui lui a donné une avance alors que
madame guilbeault a gagné cette
circonscription lors d'une élection
partielle
elle a 35 ans et on entend qu'elle sera
vice première ministre donc à la gauche
du premier ministre sur la première
rangée du salon bleu elle occupera aussi
d'autres postes importants
on entend qu'elle occupera le poste de
la sécurité publique et qu'il serait
également responsable de la région de
québec alors deux jeunes très important
aux côtés de monsieur legault ce seront
deux postes clés
on parlera aussi des postes économiques
qui seront très importants
et là monsieur legault a décidé de se
former une équipe en fait dany l'ancien
trésorier de la banque nationale
eric girard occuperait le poste occupera
le poste de ministre des finances
l'ancien vice-président la caisse de
dépôt et ancien député qui a été réélu
le 1er octobre christian dubé au trésor
et enfin pierrefitte geben un ancien
dirigeant d'entreprise occupera le poste
de ministre de l'économie c'est lui qui
sera responsable de revoir le
fonctionnement d'investissement québec
et ça c'est un projet très important aux
yeux de françois legault
monsieur legault s'entoure d'amis ce
sera un petit bol ce club parce que ces
gens là se connaissent très bien ils se
connaissent depuis plusieurs années
certains ont étudié ensemble
il se voit en dehors de leur travail de
prévision qu'on voit le trio santé
martiel on voyait à la fiche de daniel
mas kansas avait été télégraphie en
campagne électorale ça c'est pas une
surprise
lionel carmant hausse il en a beaucoup
parlé qui sera déléguée à la santé
petite enfance et marguerite blais car à
la responsabilité des aînés se savait
était pas mal le dit est clairement dit
pendant la campagne donc là on voit on
voit ce gouvernement qui prend forme
sébastien beauvais et parce que monsieur
legault leur répéter aveyronnais qui a
une seconde ses priorités à lui se sont
donc l'éducation l'économie remet de
l'argent dans la poche des québécois il
a beaucoup redit et la santé lasser les
trois grandes priorités bien sûr que la
laïcité
ils prient avec sa fille devra réagir
vite mais il veut qu'on mettre le
faisceau sur ces trois autres priorités
oui qui sont le moteur du gouvernement
et du gouvernement de coalition du
québec qui va être perçu comme le
gouvernement de l'économie donc stimuler
l'économie la santé
rappelez-vous de sa promesse de réduire
à 90 minutes le temps d'attenté dans les
urgences
c'était important et l'éducation qu'il
confiera jean françois roberge lorsqu'on
comprend 100 cd l'enseignement supérieur
et l'éducation rappelez-vous dans les
derniers gouvernements y avait deux
ministères celui de l'enseignement
supérieur à celui de l'éducation
on n'a rien entendu sur le fait que les
îles ces deux ministères la restreignent
allons voir entre excusez moi sébastien
pierre à qui l'on donne quoi de deux
délégués aux trésors d
gay au trésor exactement qui est rentré
avec madame mais cannes la prochaine
ministre de la santé qui se fera
connaître rapidement des québécois donc
oui vous vous disiez donc c'est des
postes importants en économie en
éducation et en santé vous voyez malade
mais cannes qui sera la porteuse de
dossiers dans mon corps en santé avec un
ministre délégué qui sera lionel carmant
mais il y a vous savez dans la
composition du conseil des ministres
différents critères la représentation
régionale
les expertises linge parfois aussi qui
rentrent en ligne de compte et on a
l'impression qu'ils aient un autre
critère qui a été ajoutée cette année
par monsieur legault c'est la façon de
communiquer il veut des gens qui sont
capables de bien communiquer ce que le
gouvernement veut faire les décisions du
gouvernement
rappelez vous je laime suis jamais
barrette et madame guilbeault était les
deux porteurs de la transition ils ont
reçu on la voit sébastien monsieur
j'aurais on va l'écouter assise et un
mot le bras droit premier ministre on va
voir tout à l'heure à la cérémonie mais
très certainement aujourd'hui c'est une
belle journée pour l'ensemble la
formation à caquistes si on est très
heureux d'être présent être une belle
journée alors sinon j'allais barrette
qui va symboliser le renouveau ne serait
ce que par son âge
oui il est seulement 31 hommes mais il a
déjà de l'expérience politique et ils
performent
je vous rappelle que je compare à iceman
dans topcon l'arrogance pour moi c'est à
dire qu'il ait jamais déstabilisé il
garde toujours son calme il sait comment
répondre aux questions en général ils
donnent des réponses qui sont assez
claires et donc il
il est un porte parole parfait pour le
gouvernement et comme leader
parlementaire il va aussi mener les
travaux parlementaires avec monsieur
legault il a un peu demandant quand il
le faut bref c'est l'étoile montante
masculine si on veut de la coalition
bois québec alors que l'étoile montante
féminines c'est peut-être madame guigou
vous dites leader parlementaire pour les
gens qui sont moins familiers qui les
travaux parlementaires c'est important
parce c'est lui qui fixe les priorités
et quel projet de loi sera votée en
premier qui lequel on pousse en
commission parlementaire etc
c'est un travail d'organisation plus de
coach du hac est très important il ya
toute une gestion en effet des travaux
parlementaires
qui bouffent du temps et quand on voit
que monsieur jean bart est en plus ce
qui prend à l'immigration et de la
laïcité
son assiette va être plein il a beau
avoir 31 ans ya quand même des limites à
ce qu un ministre peut faire en général
les leaders parlementaires n'avaient pas
autant de responsabilités rappelez-vous
jean marc fournier le dernier du
gouvernement était responsable des
relations intergouvernementales
canadiennes dossier oui important mais
certainement pas qu'ils occupaient à
temps plein et don qui lui permettait de
gérer les travaux parlementaires
un peu plus très bien ce qu'il y aura ce
qu'il reste et je m'adresse à tous les
camarades
est ce qu'il reste des surprises par
exemple l'environnement sap a beaucoup
fuite et je commence avec vous c'est
bastien mais est ce qu'il ya des noms
pour ce ministère qui restent qui va
être important pour donner l'image d'un
gouvernement qui se préoccupe aussi
d'environnement est le nom qui circule
c'est une surprise c'est marie chantal
chassé qui a chassé pierre moreau de ces
circonscriptions de châteauguay
rappelez-vous et madame chasse et n'a
pas à première vue les expertises
requises ou qu'on s'attendrait pour être
ministre de l'environnement c'est une
ingénieur en aéronautique je pense donc
ce serait une des surprises de ce
conseil des ministres vous voyez jean
boulet là le frère de gerry boulet qui
lui sera ministre du travail et de
l'emploi qu'on va réunir actuellement ce
sont deux ministères
il ya deux points d'interrogation je
vous dirai à première vue affaires
municipales
il y avait des informations crédibles
qui laissait entendre hier que c'était
madame rouleau c'est peut-être plus le
cas la chantal rouleau qui aurait mal à
me chasser vous la voyez là alors qu'il
rentrait à l'assemblée nationale donc il
ya un point d'interrogation sur affaires
municipales nous en quoi misent
attendent pour entrer c'est sa passion
le vin vient de parler de moi j'arrivais
mais je veux poser perles je veux pas
défaire le mythe mais c'était il ya
quelques minutes que madame je sais très
bien alors oui vous dites que madame
rouleau ne serait plus à faire ou parce
que hier on avait dit fectivement
qu'elle aurait le ministère des affaires
municipales ce ne serait plus le cas on
avait besoin à présent c'est peut-être
changé en fin d'après-midi ou en début
de soirée hier
elle serait peut-être plus tôt ministre
délégué aux transports
alors que saab la région de montréal
n'est absolument ministre responsable de
montréal de l'est de montréal et donc
les points d'interrogation qui reste
c'est à pair municipale et famille
bon ben c'est très bien alors on voit
comme ça mesdames et messieurs vous
allez voir les ministres et leurs
familles entrée à tour de rôle
il faut préciser que ça sera un
gouvernement de 26 personnes
isabelle charest qui est arrivé il ya
quelques minutes paname charest que l'on
envoie aux sports est ce qui est tout à
fait logique compte tenu de son
expérience
la triple médaillée olympique canadienne
isabelle charest qui a remporté dans les
cantons de l'est dans une
circonscription vraiment purement
libérale depuis brome missisquoi
depuis des années des années donc je
disais ça sera un madame break
on va l'écouter et que tu peux pas
parler pour lui c'est je pense qu'on est
des grains grand père sa mère et 13
voyez qu'il aura su qu'il saura faire
les bons choix au bon endroit cclat
madame alors c'est clair banham
répondants véronique presse d'autres
camarades sur le terrain est-ce qu'il
l'a fait les bons choix votre mari oui
et avec elle est déterminée madame
charest avais je pas si véronique matin
mais elle a été tout au long de cette
campagne avec son mari dans l'autobus la
plupart du temps ils sinon avec d'autres
candidats sionnel québec et on la
connaît déterminée et elle attend d'elle
et lui si ce moment là depuis fort
longtemps
alors oui sébastien de grandeur ordre de
grandeur de ce conseil des ministres 26
personnes
c'est dans la moyenne oui monsieur
legault à un moment donné a laissé
entendre qu'il voulait une vingtaine de
ministres vais une vingtaine ministre
c'est entre qu'est ce qu'on s'en sort
pour direction entre 20 et 29 mai qu'à
29 28 29 on est plus près de la
trentaine que de la vingtaine est
évidemment alors là il ira avec 26
ministres et on a l'impression que ça a
été difficile de faire passer des
nombres d à la fin du processus pour
limiter le nombre de ministres yb n'est
pas avoir plus de ministres que le
dernier conseil des ministres de
monsieur couillard certainement qu'ils
comptaient 31 ministres 33 avec le
président du caucus et le web qui
assiste également aux réunions du
conseil des ministres il est évident
qu'à 26 plus le président plus le web
donc il est en deçà de ce que monsieur
couillard a fait lors de son dernier
cabinet en même temps vous le savez
comme moi c'est comme quand on vieillit
on a en a tendance à prendre du poids
ballet conseil des ministres ont
tendance à s'élargir au fil des années
au fil du mandat donc on commence à 26
mais on verra dans quatre ans combien on
est rendu celui qui a le record là
dessus je crois sans me tromper c'est
bernard landry remaniement avant la
campagne électorale qu'il a finalement
perdu il y avait monté sa 32e l'inesss
plus trois ou quatre délégués l'un s'est
rendu à 35 avait percé de limousines
charolaises limousines savait plus où
les trouver il voulait des ministres un
peu partout dans les régions pour
s'assurer d'avoir des votes est institué
mais ça n'a pas marché de tous
très bien donc véronique oui je disais
que madame bref pour revenir un peu en
arrière on aimerait qu'on a vu entrer
est là elle a joué un rôle sans relâche
en tout cas aux côtés de son mari
cette fois ci la dernière fois également
là elle est très impliquée madame bray
elle n'aime pas être devant les cameron
ne souhaite pas particulièrement qu'on
allait la voir avec nos micros mais sur
le terrain par contre elle est très
active durant la campagne électorale
non seulement elle était aux côtés de
françois legault régulièrement ce qui
faisons en sorte que pour des des chefs
de parti d'être aux côtés de leurs
conjointes ça leur donne toujours un
espèce d'effet de proximité de personnes
accessibles à des hommes deux femmes est
finalement là c'est toujours un peu à
leur avantage de pouvoir se montrer avec
leur famille et ce à la coalition avenir
québec en a pleinement pris conscience
qu'on me demandait régulièrement de
madame rêve d' accompagner françois
legault d'autant plus que c'est une
femme qui est très chaleureuse qui aller
vers les gens qui les saluer
et lorsqu'elle n'était pas avec lui elle
faisait campagne pour lui dans des
circonscriptions comme par exemple un
petit peu partout en montérégie dans les
laurentides dans lanaudière elle allait
aider les candidats sur le terrain à
faire campagne alors aujourd'hui on
s'attendait clairement est-ce qu'elle
soit présente encore une fois aux côtés
de françois legault et je vous dirais
qu'à cette heure si la majorité des des
futurs ministres ont fait leur rentrée
je n'ai pas encore vu jean françois
roberge qu'on a pressenti qu'on a deux
confirmé d'ailleurs à radio-canada
l'éducation je n'ai pas encore aperçu
n'ai pas encore vu non plus lionel
carmant mais la majorité ont fait leur
rentrée
parce que là on va les y préparer
finalement cette argumentation qui doit
commencer très bientôt
oui on va les joindre d'ailleurs
monsieur alex boissonneault alex vous
jette là
don devant le salon rouge dans le foyer
et c'est là que les gens se rassemblent
absolument d'abord ici c'est ce qui
était à une certaine époque la chambre
où vous savez le fameux salon rouge
on va y avoir les assermentations et là
vous pouvez voir que des gens commencent
à arriver en ce moment les médias ne
peuvent pas rentrer et non les gens vous
voyez ici essentielle ment pas très ce
sont les représentants des différents
médias écrits la télévision aussi est
juste à côté vous avez manqué risque
aguilar mais beaucoup de proches des
gens qui qui ont été candidats aussi
pour la coalition avenir québec celui
que j'ai eu en contre svetlana sous le
mit qui naquit est monté ici était
candidate malheureuse dans jean talon
donc les gens attendent qu'ils vont
faire leur rentrée des jeux il y en a
qui ont commencé à faire leur entrée
dans le salon devant la salle du conseil
les choisir dans le salon rouge
évidemment ce qu'on veut surveiller
c'est ce sont les gens qui se trouvent à
prendre place les nouveaux députés parce
que tous les députés doivent être là on
me voir s'il y en a qui manquent à
l'appel
on va voir la réaction évidemment dans
la salle mon coup droit aussi six ans
membres n'ont peut-être que ça peut
laisser entendre que des gens qui sont
déçus du cours des choses parce que
peut-être ils n'ont pas leur place au
conseil des ministres
donc ces réactions le sont quand même
important
oui ça serait un très très très mal vu
de bouder entre guillemets aujourd'hui
alors c'est un nouveau gouvernement
qu'on veut insuffler de l'optimisme
verrou mais entre la personne qui fait
ça c'est ce message de répandre les les
épaules assez solides
je donne aux gens ont pu l'aperçu de
l'horaire 14h donc en un sens ça
commence en principe à l'heure et un par
un les ministres vont venir prêter
serment auront donc leur responsabilité
et à la suite de quoi après vingt-six
comme ça 26 ministres qui viendront
parler
le premier ministre va faire un discours
et c'est un discours qui pas très long
mais qui est important parce
qu'habituellement c'est vraiment là
c'est pas au discours du trône mais
c'est la table des matières c'est là où
on veut aller
le premier ministre sébastien puis c'est
important alors il va répéter on imagine
avec beaucoup beaucoup de clarté
éducation santé économie remet de
l'argent il va vouloir replacer ses
priorités au centre du discours
politique
aujourd'hui et donner des mandats très
clair à chacun des ministres
c'est ça voir le chemin ouvrir le chemin
c'est ministres qui vont avoir le mandat
notamment pour monsieur brighi bonne
l'économie par exemple de réformes et
investissement québec c'est une promesse
un monsieur roberge en éducation de
revamper nos écoles d'améliorer la
réussite scolaire alors vous voyez tous
les défis qui vont pouvoir apparaître
devant ses ministres évêques sont nommés
aujourd'hui c'est un peu comme des
lettres de mandat dans une certaine
mesure où on leur dit quelle sera leur
mire mandat quelle sera leur mission
monsieur legault quand il est sorti du
bureau du lieutenant gouverneur a dit
nous aurons un gouvernement qui va
livrer la marchandise nous voulons
livrer des résultats stopper là la
proche du monde des affaires de monsieur
de goût la performance il savait marquer
son passage au ministère de la santé au
ministère de l'éducation lorsqu'il était
avec le parti québécois
donc on voit un peu se dessine est
devant nous la façon dont monsieur
legault veut gérer son gouvernement on
va aller voir hugo lavallée qui est
accompagné de gens autour de lui des
familles parce que bien sûr hugo c'est
une journée importante pour le ou la
ministre
et je répète il y aura treize ministres
est une espère donc treize hommes 13
femmes une journée importante pour la
famille ont également qui verront leur
mode de vie changer dramatiquement wii
et qui risque d'avoir des conjoints ou
des conjointes pas mal moins disponibles
au cours des prochains mois il ya
beaucoup beaucoup de fébrilité ici aussi
même si on n'a pas vu des lui ni de
ministres pressentis défilé ils sont
amenés dès leur entrée dans une pièce
derrière le salon rouge là où ils se
préparent en vue de la cérémonie on a vu
quand même des membres de leur famille
par exemple le conjoint de geneviève
guilbeault rappelez vous madame
guilbeault est enceinte lors de
l'élection partielle dans louis-hébert
son conjoint était ici avec sa petite
fille tout à l'heure c'est eu des
moments évidemment émouvant pour les
membres de la famille il ya beaucoup de
gens aussi dans l'entourage de la cac
qui ont été là ces dernières années
comme bénévole comme organisateurs sur
le terrain qu'on a reconnu qu'on a vu
passer à derrière nous au cours des
dernières minutes qui donc se préparent
à cette cérémonie des invités aussi du
futur gouvernement
le président-directeur général
d'hydro-québec par exemple est arrivé
tout à l'heure il va assister à la
cérémonie on a aussi vu des
représentants d'organisations de la
société civile de syndicats dont des
gens qui ont été invités par le
gouvernement pour cette cérémonie par la
suite
il y aura également en privé une
cérémonie d'accueil où ils pourront donc
rencontrer les nouveaux ministres lors
les saluer les féliciter donc une
ambiance de fébrilité quand même pas mal
de gens qui défilent ils sont accueillis
puis se dirige tout en haut de
l'escalier vers le salon c'est un moment
évidemment important pour la vie
démocratique des québécois c'est la
formation d'un nouveau gouvernement
donc c'est d'autant plus important une
nouvelle couleur une coalition la
coalition bois québec c'est une réelle
coalition et dans les choix des chefs de
cabinet pour tous ces mines et cela
c'est fascinant de voir messieurs dames
qui a beaucoup beaucoup de libéraux qui
a beaucoup de paix qu'est ce donc c'est
vraiment de réunir les deux grandes
tendances politiques des 40 50 dernières
années pour en faire une nouvelle force
politique on verra jusqu'où tout seul
nous mènera véronique on parlait de la
famille la mère du problème dé ses
entrées à quelques minutes et voilà les
membres de la famille entre aussi par
cette porte j'ai cru apercevoir aussi
l'un des fils de françois legault
je pense aussi que c'était sa soeur mais
c'est finalement sa mère qui a accepté
de nous parler voici ce que nous a dit
oui je suis fier de mon fils je le donne
9 heures pot c'est bonjour c'est très
bon beaucoup de fermeté et ben voila
voila on voit d'où ça vient
c'est très bon ouais semble avoir du
caractère madame legault à l'arrêt li
membre la famille comment ça continue
d'arriver comme ça et je veux juste vous
signaler en pensant qu'il ya des flots
qu ici comme un malheur légende des
pêches à entrer pour alice réchauffer un
petit peu et oui il a des flots quand il
fait froid québec c'est très bien l'ex
vous avez des informations sur ce que
vaut 10
je souligne l importance de ce discours
là on va dire monsieur lebon donc sur le
déroulement aux 6 à 14 ans et ça va
commencer tout ça monsieur legault ne
présentera pas selon les informations
qu'on donne chacun des ministres chacune
des personnes qui prendra place au
conseil des ministres mais ils vont
faire une allocution offert un discours
après après la présentation de
l'ensemble du conseil où il va parler du
gouvernement qu'il veut incarner un
gouvernement qui marquera ce point là
qu'il veut proche des préoccupations des
québécois et des québécoises
donc il va rappeler les priorités de son
gouvernement et ses priorités sont le
déjà entendu dire sont l'éducation
l'économie la santé avec un rappel des
grands projets qui ont été présentés
devant la campagne électorale donc si on
parle d'éducation par exemple
l'importance qu'il veut donner à au
dépistage des troubles d'apprentissage
chez les jeunes en économie remettre de
l'argent dans le portefeuille des
québécois s'ils veulent rappeler encore
une fois ce qu'il veut réduire le
fardeau fiscal de l'ensemble des
québécois et des québécoises est aussi
améliorée dans un futur rapproché
l'accès à des soins de première ligne
est aussi un soutien amélioré pour les
proches aidants non ce sont des projets
dont il a déjà parlé mais qu'il entend
bien rappeler aujourd'hui à la fed a
sévèrement éliminée sera l'ex après la
cérémonie quelques minutes pas tous mais
vont faire des petits points de presse
est là si ces classiques on en recevra
d'ailleurs à l'émission tout à l'heure
mais ses classiques haut
très rapidement quand les questions
deviennent plus pointus ont du coup tu
es là je vais lire mais les cahiers de
dressage qui sont soit des pères avant
de pouvoir vous donner des réponses plus
précises donc ce n'est pas aujourd'hui
qu'on aura des défunts détail des
politiques ont d'autant plus qu' il va y
avoir une première rencontre savons-nous
est en mesure de confirmer qu entre la
cérémonie il va y avoir une prise
d'image de l'ensemble de cette nouvelle
équipe qui est formé du visage de
gouvernement non qu'on présentera aux
gens et après ça ils voyent avant une
réunion du conseil des ministres dont on
ne tarde pas à se réunir probablement
procéder à des nominations peut-être
important pour la transition parle aussi
des priorités des projets de chacun ce
qu'on veut donner comme ligne directrice
à chacun des ministres donc des gens se
met au travail
sébastien martin j'aimerais vous
demander le d'après vous qu'est-ce qui a
été le plus difficile difficile à faire
pour un monsieur legault dans les
dernières heures
est ce que ce n'est pas de dire non à
des gens qui sont là depuis souvent le
début de la cac et qu'on ne peut pas
entrer au conseil des ministres
c'est la chose la plus difficile et
c'est ce que tout premier ministre pas
seulement monsieur legault vie à chaque
fois qu'ils forment conseil des
ministres les gens qui sont laissés de
côté et ne sais pas c'est difficile
parce que ça crée de la déception je
vous dis pas que des 74 députés de la
coalition a mené québec se voyait au
conseil des ministres
mais il y en a certainement beaucoup
plus que les 26 qui sont nommés
aujourd'hui qui se voyait au conseil des
ministres donc il faut gérer la
déception fiona avec leurs années de
service qui se disent je devrais pouvoir
accéder au conseil des ministres
j'ai une feuille de route où j'ai bien
travaillé oui je suis peut-être un homme
de 40 50 60 ans mais je peux apporter
quelque chose et ils sont laissés de
côté à cause de critères qui vont au
delà de la compétence ou des années de
service la représentation régionale
l'orage parfois parité entre les hommes
et les femmes à partir du moment où
voulez vous voulez y arriver ça élimine
certaines personnes et donc il ya très
certainement de la déception et c'est ça
qui est plus difficile à gérer lorsque
aux formes côté du mythe
je vais vous montrer un tableau par la
chorale temps parce que quand ça va
commencer ça va défiler bien sûr cette
émission je vous rappelle mesdames et
messieurs c'est à 14h que nous aurons
donc un à un la venue
nouveau ministre la répartition des
sièges par région
pourquoi je vous parle de ça donc ça
c'est la répartition à l'assemblée
nationale ce sont 14 29 10 10 mais voilà
c'est petit mais rester avec moi si vous
voulez quelques secondes
l'île de montréal il ya que deux députés
qui ont été élus d'ici là les
laurentines 19 en montérégie alors c'est
sûr que les 19 en montérégie
comme vous le dites sébastien on peut
pas peut pas faire monter au conseil des
ministres
tellement plus que 2,3 parce qu'ils vont
avoir un déséquilibre régional à ce
moment là c'est ça en même temps si vous
en avez 19 en montérégie peut-être vous
en avez quatre ou cinq qui s'en vont au
conseil des ministres
il y avait peut-être un seulement au
saguenay lac saint jean il ya peut-être
moins dans d'autres régions
prenez la région de québec qui a
toujours été à la base du support de la
coalition bois québec et avança de la dq
combien vous nommer le ministre dans la
région de québec alors que si je vois
bien dans la capitale nationale vous en
avez vite ministre on comprend qu'il y
en aura trois sur les bêtes c'est quand
même une représentation assez grosse en
mauricie il y en aurait deux sur les
quatre qui ont été élus si vous prenez
strictement la mauricie il ya quatre
circonscriptions qui ont basculé du côté
de la coalition de québec qui en a 7 ans
tout si vous êtes incorporer le centre
du québec
mais sur les quatre de la mauricie il ya
deux ministres qui vont accéder de
députés qui vont accéder au conseil des
ministres donc il peut y avoir des
déséquilibres dans certaines régions et
il peut y avoir des régions qui se
sentent délaissés aussi à certains
égards très bien puis comme vous dites
mais on l'a beaucoup répéter la parité
c'est en terme de nombre bien sûr 13
femmes 13 hommes sans termes de
responsabilité aussi
il fallait martin je pense martin
m'entends il fallait que comme sur le go
tiennent aussi compte de l'importance
des ministères qu'il allait accorder aux
femmes
c'est un exercice excessivement
difficile hier les téléphones que j'ai
fait on m'a dit que c'était douloureux
et que monsieur legault voulait
respecter cet engagement de parité parce
qu'au début de la semaine on parlait
davantage de nous on parie terre parce
que monsieur legault a fait élire 38%
son caucus sont des femmes donc il est
un peu en mode la zone paritaire
se demandait si j'arriverai à faire
remplir cet engagement là et on s'est
dit non on commence pas ce mandat là en
brisant une promesse monsieur legault a
tenu à ce qu'il y ait autant de femmes
que donne mais ça a été très difficile
particulièrement pour les anciens
caquistes qui siège avec monsieur
legault et quelques vedettes on parlait
de la montérégie où monsieur legault a
fait élire presque toutes les
circoncisions des députés n'a presque
toutes les circonscriptions
et oui à plusieurs vedettes comme jean
françois roberge lionel carmant simon
jaulin barrette nathalie roy alors
quelqu'un comme ian lafrenière par
exemple que monsieur legault a recruté
qui était considéré comme une vedette
devra attendre son tour
la beauté finalement c'est qu'avec
conseil des ministres de 26 personnes
d'aï reste encore un peu de place et le
message qu'on a aussi envoyé c'est que
tout le monde doit être testé les choses
ne sont pas faits ce n'est pas une
situation une affectation permanente que
de siéger au conseil des ministres et
monsieur legault pourrait revoir les
choses un peu plus tard dans le mandat
s'il y avait des complications dans un
ministère ou l'autre à l'onda fait
patienter les gens une chose qu'a fait
monsieur legault hier c'est qu'après
avoir formé son conseil des ministres
mardi soir et hier matin il a aussi
rencontré d'autres députés qui n'ont pas
été choisis pour les rassurer et leur
proposer certaines affectations soit une
présidence de commission soit
l'assemblée nationale alors on tente de
contenter ou d'occuper toutes ces
personnes et de dire le temps est long 1
sébastien puis oui pour la première
année voici à quoi ressemblera mon
gouvernement mais ça peut changer puis
c'est pas parce que vous n'êtes pas loin
la première fois vous serez pas là la
deuxième fois et c'était à cet espoir là
qu'ils vont s'accrocher les déçus parce
que quatre ans ça peut être long en
effet dans leur laisse entendre que
quatre ans c'est long en effet pour la
politique et que les choses peuvent
changer
je sur la question des parités je sais
pas si alex avec dc un beau tout à
l'heure parce que
j'étais distrait mais on me dit que les
ministres vont être présentés en
alternance hommes femmes lorsqu'ils
entreront dans le salon rouge sur sur la
question de deux ministres en attente ou
en fait de députés qui vont qui espère
adhérer au cabinet je vous rappelle le
cabinet de jean charest en 2007 ils
avaient ils étaient minoritaires ils
avaient décidé de former un petit
cabinet de 24 personnes et il avait fait
élire pierre arcand dans la
circonscription de
morial et il avait dû attendre son tour
il a siégé sur les banquettes pendant
tout le mandat
et aujourd'hui il est le chef par
intérim
c'est ça mais parce que pourquoi tant de
gens veulent accéder à cette table où
c'est que sébastien c'est bien beau de
dire comme l'a dit monsieur legault il
ya deux jours
vous savez le gouvernement de la caq ce
n'est pas simplement les ministres mais
c'est toute la députation les 74
il reste que l'exécutif dans notre
système politique
si le conseil des ministres puis conseil
des ministres c'est là autour de cette
table que se prennent toutes les
décisions importantes du québec
oui et c'est la raison pour laquelle
tout le monde que c'est veut siéger
autour de cette grande table assez
l'épicentre politique du gouvernement
sauf que l'art de bien faire la
politique et de bien mener un
gouvernement c'est de garder les canaux
de communication ouvert entre le caucus
donc entre les 74 et le conseil des
ministres donc des 26 matches qui sont
au conseil des ministres
parlez-en philippe couillard on a
compris que la fin de son mandat parfois
la communication était difficile avec
son caucus et un caucus qui est pas
content c'est au caucus qui fonctionne
mal et dont la solidarité peut
s'effriter à l'ordre on pense qu'une
personne proposée il ne faut oublier
personne
alors qu'est ce qu'on fait on distribue
des postes de présidents de commissions
parlementaires d'adjoint parlementaire
on va envoyer des gens en mission va
leur confier certains mandats aussi pas
pour les occuper des serments mais pour
s'assurer qu'ils restent satisfaits de
leurs fonctions tout en rappelant que la
fonction première
c'est la fonction de député ou au
service des gens qui ont élu ces
personnes à la chambre et on nous dit
dans l'entourage de monsieur legault que
le premier ministre désigné a tiré les
leçons du mandat de philippe couillard
tout au long des quatre dernières années
eu beaucoup de difficulté à à connecter
avec son caucus et que monsieur legault
veut remédier à cette situation là alors
il a devant lui un défi de cohésion
qu'il veut relever il
il se fait un point d'ordre d'essayer de
rester le plus proche possible de son
caucus
et d'ailleurs on peut revenir au
discours d'assermentation de mardi où on
a vu françois legault très humain qui
voulait être beaucoup plus proche de ses
députés
aujourd'hui on devrait avoir un discours
beaucoup plus sur sa vision du québec
ces visions du changement du québec
j'aimerais vous entendre sur une autre
question et j'en parlais rapidement tout
à l'heure je donne l exemple des chefs
de cabinet qui proviennent et des
libéraux et des péquistes
monsieur legault lui même ancien
ministre souverainiste qui s'est entouré
de gens donc deux libéraux dans certains
cas de fédérale et on n'a peut-être pas
assez souligné se fait depuis l'élection
de ce gouvernement là mais je commence
avec vous sébastien c'est quand même une
première depuis 50 ans où on arrive à
faire l'addition de forces
souverainistes et fédéralistes pour en
faire quelque chose d'autre
et là dessus en tout cas le le pendant
qu'on voit régis labeaume qui veulent
assister à cette cérémonie bien sûr là
dessus c'est remarquable quand même oui
c'est parce que c'est la première fois
depuis 1970 que ce ne sont pas les
libéraux et les péquistes qui sont au
pouvoir donc quand vous parliez de la
page d'histoire qui est écrite
aujourd'hui première fois depuis
soixante dix que un nouveau parti accède
au pouvoir
mais si la bombe enfin converti mais sur
la banque si vous avez bien on va voir
on a peur d'eux
labeaume elle s'est d'abord de quoi des
attentes particulières pour ce que vous
je compte avec lui c'est pour les gens
qui sont cachés dans quelques mois c'est
la bombe sur le veau a tant fait selon
moi je sais pas d'endroit il ya
peut-être eu beau savoir dans quelques
minutes là on l'appellera après la
marche dans la région septième fois
[Rires]
là où l monsieur la banque qui a neuf
vies dont est effectivement dus à sa
septième fois sébastien martin à lui il
s'énerve pas quoique il ya des dossiers
qui lie qui l'énervent un peu un mot
là-dessus c'est brice hier il ya le
troisième bien évidemment si bien que au
début de la semaine y avait une rumeur
selon laquelle éric caire pourrait être
ministre délégué aux transports
responsables du troisième ligne 1 comme
véronique tremblay une ministre libéral
de l'argent québec et ministre délégué
aux transports responsables du troisième
bien on comprend que le ministre des
transports ce sera françois bonnardel et
que chantal rouleau de montréal pourrait
être la ministre déléguée donc pour la
construction du troisième vingt pour le
tramway aussi qui sera construit à
québec
monsieur labeaume devra se référer à des
interlocuteurs qui ne sont pas de la
région de québec
je sais pas si ça lui déplaît mais
disons que la communication est plus
facile quand vous savez que le ministre
habite dans votre ville premier point
deuxième point il va avoir comme
interlocutrice principal pour les
dossiers de la capitale nationale
geneviève guilbeault qui est l'étoile
féminine montante du gouvernement
à première vue il devrait pas y avoir de
problème du moins sur la personnalité de
chacun monsieur labeaume peut parfois
avoir une personnalité un peu abrasive
mais madame qu'il boon ne projette pas
cette image là alors il ça devrait quand
même bien aller à première vue avec
madame guilbault alors je reviens ce que
je disais oui pour la première fois un
troisième papa pour la première fois ce
que le parti québécois l'avait fait mais
une troisième voie mais qui est formé
d'une partie de chacun de ces deux
grands partis pq et le plq et chefs de
cabine est un peut être au centre de
l'opération pour un ministre c'est
vraiment le bras droit à des démineurs
et il ya des libéraux notoires des
péquistes au toit qui sont dans cette
aventure nouvelle martin yu nan mais me
recruter pendant la campagne électorale
des chefs de cabinet qui siégeaient qui
étaient en exercice dans certains
ministères alors will cette coalition la
veut se faire et on s'en va à
l'intérieur je crois oui en savent à
l'intérieur alors ce petit garçon lui a
beaucoup de plaisir à jouer avec la
table la tablette à la bonne hauteur
pour le petit garçon je ne sais pas à
qui il est mais il certainement pas
perdu alors voyez des images les
familles les amis les ministres qui vont
en prendre place et tout devant ce qu'on
découvre ensemble c'est le nombre de
chaises donc pour les nouveaux ministres
alors en principe il y en a 26 plus le
président du caucus plus le whip ou la
whip alors c'est normal qu'ils aient
plus de chaises que de nombre de mines
est à proprement parler
alors c'est ici que ça va se faire c'est
ici dans cette dans ce salon rouge où se
tient ces cérémonies depuis toujours
sébastien martinez je le disais c'est un
moment important de notre processus
notre vie démocratique c'est là où on
apprend qui va gouverner à proprement
parler le québec au cours ont moins de
la prochaine année avant qu'il ya des
changements ministériels après après les
succursales société québécoise du
cannabis est l'endroit le plus court il
lui dirait au québec parce qu'il y aura
tellement de monde qu'on se demandait si
on serait capable d'accueillir tout le
monde dans le vaste salon rouge les cas
qui seront à éviter beaucoup de
m'envoyer même la galerie
va être occupé et il ya énormément de
journalistes également qu'ils ont été
accrédités pour l'événement
il ya beaucoup de fébrilité à
l'assemblée nationale en fait depuis le
début de la semaine mais aujourd'hui
c'est particulier peut-être parce que
c'est un nouveau gouvernement et d'un
gouvernement de recrues alors cette
journée non seulement chaque ministre
invite les membres de sa famille mais
aussi les bénévoles qui ont été très
importants dans leur circonscription
c'est un moment de joie finalement très
symbolique très fort aujourd'hui où on
envoie les signaux et après hausse mais
la tâche très bien vous parlez de
signaux bon si on l'a beaucoup dit 13-13
la parité donc ça sera rempli le nombre
de femmes élues à la caq ses 28 sur 74
donc si je calcule rapidement ses 38
pour ça deux femmes à la dq donc c'était
un
c'est un effort à faire pour une parité
parfaite 50 50 mais vous l'avez dit plus
tôt martin il y tenait monsieur legault
et sébastien ne voulait pas briser cette
promesse la première journée d'espoir
ccc c'est important pour lui de bien
commencer ça donne un certain signal
parce que c'est un gouvernement de
recrues et monsieur legault veut prendre
son temps pour essayer d'éviter les
impairs et les faux pas et les gaffes
il y en aura c'est inévitable mais on
aimerait que ce ministre là fassent leur
travail correctement avant de se
présenter publiquement alors on ne croit
pas que la chambre que l'assemblée
nationale ne sera rappelé avant la fin
du mois de novembre pour que chacun de
ses ministres puissent lire ces
documents de briefing se faire une tête
est aussi passé à travers ce qu'on
appelle le processus du drap et ron ce à
dire où on met les ministres à l'épreuve
des questions des journalistes c'est
reconnu que la presse parlementaire est
redoutable et assez difficile
alors on va vouloir rdée cette équipe là
et comme sébastien le disent un peu plus
tôt monsieur legault a quand même fait
une attention particulière de choisir
des personnalités qui ont une capacité
de communicateurs pour faire passer le
message
alors attendez vous à ce qu'il soit
plutôt absent de vue de la caméra au
cours des prochaines semaines surtout en
ce qui a trait aux nouveaux on veut une
grande discipline aussi c'est ce qu'on
nous indique est qu'on étale à québec la
faire l'entrevue avec le premier
ministre désigné
vous qui savez tout sébastien il faudra
dire à qui sont ces enfants passent de
la vedette de cette émission pour
l'assermentation des ministres donc je
referme la parenthèse oui on veut
insuffler une grande discipline on se
souvient du début du gouvernement marois
en 2012 où on tirait sur tout ce qui
bouge en même temps on veut donner a
vraiment l'impression ces bassins c'est
important qu'on est discipliné alors le
moddeur dominé ces avant de parler
faites vos devoirs
oui et à la différence du gouvernement
marois que gouvernement marois était un
gouvernement minoritaire et avait comme
un sentiment d'urgence d'un gouvernement
marois pour remonter sa cote de
popularité et éventuellement déclencher
des élections et remporter ces élections
l'histoire nous a appris finalement que
la route a été pavée de toutes sortes de
nids-de-poule pour le pq ici à la
différence
la coalition bois québec a du temps du
temps pour mettre en place ces
politiques qui sont parfois ambitieuse
réduire les taxes municipales par
exemple construire les maisons des aînés
s'assurer que le temps d'attendre dans
les auges ans diminue s'assurer que les
écoles augmentent leur taux de
diplomation et deviennent de véritables
milieux de vie donc il ya beaucoup de
projets sur la table mais on a le temps
les concrétiser ce qui m'étonne un peu
c'est que monsieur legault en même temps
politiquement c'est peut-être une
stratégie qui qui qui va lui sourire
mais veut y aller rapidement sur la
question de la laïcité parce qu'on a
l'impression que c'est un espèce de péta
la laïcité qui peut exploser à tout
moment mais probablement que son
raisonnement c'est qu'il veut mettre ce
dos il a derrière lui rapidement pour
passer à d'autres choses et de plus
fondamental à ses yeux comme l'économie
la santé ou à l'éducation
donc ce gouvernement là il doit en effet
être discipliné parce qu'il veut
des résultats comme l'a dit monsieur
legault sur l'heure du midi et pour
livrer des résultats il doit être
disciplinée doit être prudent aussi et
faire les choses chacune à leur tour
c'est sur la laïcité c'est peut-être pas
innocent que monsieur legault donne ce
dossier là à simon jaulin bar est non
seulement il est jeune mais il a aussi
des qualités et c'est à dire qu'il a des
études doctorales en droit
constitutionnel
c'est lui qui d'ailleurs au cours du
dernier mandat comme porte parole dans
l'opposition a déposé le plus de projets
de loi privés
il a il a un intérêt pour la procédure
parlementaire
c'est peut-être qu'il est peut-être plus
équipés même que madame le bel dans ce
sens
madame lebel vont en avoir plein son
assiette avec le ministère de la justice
monsieur jallet barrette a certainement
une plus grande expérience du processus
parce que plusieurs étapes à suivre et
ce sera très certainement un dossier que
ceux-ci moment difficile et sur le sur
l'immigration et la laïcité c'est quand
même particulier d'avoir le même porteur
de ballon à la fois pour les migrations
et pour la laïcité
monsieur legault va devoir répondre à la
question est ce que vous faites un lien
entre immigration et menaces à la
laïcité de l'état menace entre
guillemets dans la mesure où voulait
interdire les signes religieux est ce
que vous faites pas un lien entre la
laïcité et l'immigration où les flows
que l'immigration peut avoir sur la
protection ou le danger lié à la laïcité
de l'état et ça je pense qu'on va on est
en attente d'une explication
écoutez ces bassesses voulait bien
l'ancien président de l'assemblée
c'est la fin de mon mandat
et d'annuler votre voyage en australie
façon je ne penserai pas je ne passerai
pas toujours d'être sinon façon moi je
pense plutôt qu'est ce que ça vous fait
d'être ici aujourd'hui c'est quand même
soit un moment important dans longtemps
c'est un nouveau parti ce qu'on apprend
vite 1970 ce qu'est ce que ça vous fait
c'est justement historiquement parlant
c'est très intéressant quand même temps
à ce qu'une concerne je suis peut-être
moins émotivement appris que d'autres
d'abord j'ai choisi depuis un bon bout
de temps depuis des années de ne pas me
représenter
alors dans ces circonstances comment mon
deuil est certainement moins
- g je prends note côte d'eich très
serein c'est un monsieur paradis dans le
processus de rapprochement
j'arrive de sommet des chefs d'état de
la francophonie sur le big air soir et
puis je vois que j'ai vu dans les
journaux que monsieur paradis était
probablement celui qui voulait se
présenter pour la succession
mais ceux qui sont au seuil et si vous
aviez un conseil à lui donner
on devrait toujours ouverts d'esprit
ouvert à tous ses collègues de
l'assemblée parce que le président de
l'assemblée doit être
pour être efficace il y aura la
confiance de tous les membres
d'assemblées de tous les partis des
chefs des leaders et je pense que
monsieur paradis sera très bon sens du
verset 10 a dit qu'il voulait une
présidence plus transparente a fait
référence peut-être certains sur les
controverses que ce soit si bon je suis
pas je pars situations de contres versé
que personne puis j'ai pas bien sûr que
chaque président amène avec lui son
style et 100 et 100 apache
moi j'aurais fait des modifications
importantes
je fais plusieurs révolutions
n'intéresse parlement avait faut dire
que
j'aurais été présent longtemps ce qui
est peu du club de personnages étaient
présents sur trois différents peluche
nature et avec 3 différents premier
ministre j'ai eu l'occasion de changer
beaucoup de choses dans le parlement
j'ai pas dû changer il reste d'autres
choses sont inquiétude par rapport à ce
nouveau gouvernement la peau du cou si
vous gardez votre devoir de réserve
maintenant vous allez vous en parlez
vous allez retrouver la liberté
oui monsieur je fais pas la dernière non
plus jamais un esprit très partisan
cependant des raisons pour lesquelles on
m'a choisi trois fois de suite pour être
prises dans ce domaine
lorsque j'étais membre de l'opposition
officielle en 2012 m'a demandé
unanimement d'être d'être président
alors n'ont jamais souffert de grande
partie d'année ils surveillaient
aujourd'hui où la proposition générale
mais je pense avoir dû d'un jour ne plus
compter pour trouver simplement
l'utilisent avec on laisse assez de
place aux femmes aux jeunes par exemple
on doit le sud beaucoup de place aux
femmes parce que son maître à kenzy
beaucoup de place aux femmes dit-il
jacques chagnon ex président de
l'assemblée nationale un petit mot
sébastien et martin jacques chagnon qui
ont il ya eu il ya eu ces controverses
d'ailleurs avec boissonneault avec
raison lui a rappelé sur les dépenses
sur des dîners au homard et c'est là on
reviendra pas sur tout ça mais lui dit
j'ai jamais été prêt très partisan et
c'est pour ça que je jamais occupé ce
poste sébastien c'est effectivement un
pass ou ou françois paradis si c'est
confirmé on croit que ça le sera s'il
doit s'élever au dessus de la
partisanerie oui et on veut donner une
nouvelle nouvel élan sur veut à la
présidence de l'assemblée nationale à la
coalition bois québec notamment avec
plus de transparence plus de
transparence sur les dépenses la
pression on sait gérer les voyages aussi
parce qu'il ya beaucoup de voyages des
missions qui probablement ont leur
importance la question qu'on se pose
c'est si autant de monde doivent y
participer à chaque fois donc dans
l'esprit de ou monsieur legault aborde
son côté des ministres avec de meilleurs
communicateurs
il aborde la présidence avec le même
esprit en désignant françois paradis
pour devenir le prochain président de
l'assemblée
c'est quelqu'un qui est capable de bien
communiquer on sait de façon générale je
termine là dessus les gens saluent quand
même
l'oeuvre de jacques chagnon on retient
oui les soirées bien arrosées les
nombreux voyages mais de façon générale
les partis les députés reconnaissent que
monsieur chagnon a fait à l'intérieur de
l'enceinte du bon travail
bien sûr champions où ils vont être
reconnu comme le président qui a bu le
vin jusqu'à la lie ils étaient endormis
ni la semaine dernière mais
effectivement changé non là c'est un
député
mais il reste monsieur chagnon a été par
moment écartée mais on l'a ramené c'est
un président qui a su tenir la
discipline à l'intérieur je vous avais
tu le second que tu étais très respecté
pendant qu'on voit le livre la table ou
où les ministres prêteront serment je
veux éclairer les gens parce que hier il
ya eu sébastien martin cette controverse
enfin les député de québec solidaire ont
refusé de prêter serment la reine
publiquement ils l'ont fait derrière
pour ce qui est des ministres sébastien
donc c'est un processus qui est
similaire
oui je te prends tu sais juste qu'il
simulait où il prête serment on était je
te peu fou dans mon esprit s'ils m'ont
prêté ce jeu parce qu'ils prêtent
serment en arrière et qu'il vienne en
avant après mais prenez pas par là
dessus saison le choix en fait ils
peuvent le faire cesser selon la
décision du premier ministre
comment il veut arranger ça comme madame
marois avait choisi de parler aussi
avant chaque nomination et de dire ce
qu'elle est ce qu'elle s'attendait de
chacun ça ne sera pas le cas là monsieur
legault va parler uniquement mais à la
fin dans les années en 2012 les
ministres du parti québécois avait prêté
serment en privé après c'est y avait un
discours de pauline marois en public
faut comprendre et des fois les gens le
perdre de vue c'est que l'exécutif donc
le gouvernement était en place jusqu'à
aujourd'hui
martin coiteux était toujours ministre
de la sécurité publique et ministre des
affaires municipales
même s'ils n'étaient plus de députés à
l'assemblée nationale par exemple
et aujourd'hui c'est là qu'on tourne la
page d'ailleurs juste en bas de la rue
ici il ya la ligne
mende véhicule de fonction des gardes du
corps qui est là et chacun des gardes du
corps dans la mécanique de la patente la
attend de savoir avec quel ministre il
sera dorénavant jumelées donc il ya un
espèce de ballet qui se déroule
actuellement à l'assemblée nation très
bien monsieur picard me dit on dit
quelques mots on va l'écouter becqueter
de façon globale sans nommer
spécifiquement des enjeux que son pote à
certaines communautés où certaines
nations la relation politique c'est
vraiment le premier point à l'ordre du
jour il faut bien la définir mais il
faut aussi la définir avec une présence
et notre collaboration
si c'est le gouvernement du québec qui
décide tout seul
comment cette heure-là sur l'autre
devrait être défini alors y aura
évidemment une un ou une ministre
responsable des affaires autochtones
sébastien et martin lors de cette
cérémonie qui je vous le souligne
mesdames et messieurs va commencer
maintenant dans quoi six minutes très
exactement où on va voir arriver puis un
take two le protocole qu'il se doit ou i
martin web il ya une rumeur pour le
ministère des affaires autochtones et ce
serait s'il vit d'amour qui est la
députée de mirabel
on souligne par contre qu'elle ne parle
pas anglais mais ce n'est pas la
première fois qu'un ministre responsable
des affaires autochtones qui me parlent
pas anglais c'était le cas de madame
laroche mais elle était située dans la
région de l'abitibi témiscamingue où il
y a des
des réserves autochtones ce qui est
moins le cas dans la région de mirabel
alors on verra si monsieur picard et
madame d'amour pourront s'entendre et le
dossier d'appui yade sera un des
premiers sur la liste
oui vous avez aperçu si vous me
permettez patrice vous avez aperçu sur
les images qu'on vend en direct
youri chassin oui on n'entend pas parler
de youri chassin dans les rumeurs de
deux ministres qui seront nommés
aujourd'hui on a l'impression qu'il sera
écarté du conseil des ministres
aujourd'hui voilà lui aurait espéré bien
sûr c'était une de ses vedettes on a
parlé tout à l'heure de de monsieur
lafleur pour la première mais oui oui
monsieur la fronière j'avais raison ce
paradis que l'on voie qui sera donc le
nouveau président vraisemblablement de
l'assemblée nationale et on voit juste
derrière chantal soucy qui est pressenti
pour être une des vice présidente de
l'assemblée nationale alors il
travaillerait avec ce monsieur paradis
l'autre vice président ce serait marc
picard qui lui aspirer au poste de
président de l'assemblée nationale et
qui est un peu déçu certainement
aujourd'hui déçus mais en même temps on
ne voudra pas faire ni de évidemment pas
de coup d'éclat ni trop de boudin parce
que la prochaine fois peut arriver et on
ne veut pas laisser cette impression
d'être mauvais joueur comme youri
chassin on serait très surpris qu'il
révèle à haute voix sa déception
sébastien là je pense qu'elle comprend
bien ce qui est en train de se passer
si vous voulez rester dans les bonnes
grâces si vous avez l'impression que le
très prochain en gare puis que vous
n'avez pas réussi à monter dans
aujourd'hui ne faites pas d'esclandres
oui on bien présente et vous présentez
vous à l'assermentation ayez un grand
sourire sur les lèvres est dit que tout
est parfait dans le meilleur des mondes
et que vous aimez votre rôle de député
et le train pourrait repasser en gardant
quelques mois sinon quel que soit bien
députés un jeune dire louis le mur parce
qu on vient de le voir
lemieux qui au début de cette campagne
la n'avait absolument aucune idée qui se
retrouveraient députés à l'assemblée
nationale
il a remplacé à pied levé ce malheureux
candidat de la cac qui a eu des
problèmes dans son bar dans saint jean
dont qui les deux c'est ça lui est tombé
dessus comme la providence ils étaient
déjà associés sur une bande d étaient
déjà associés à la coalition a mené à
québec du géant dames façon ils
faisaient les capsules vidéo est
diffusée sur le web pour la carte
monsieur laframboise qu'on aperçoit
également un vieux routier lui dans les
laurentides bloc québécois anciennement
perçu comme le sage un peu de ce caucus
là on le pressent présidente du caucus
donc il ne sera pas décisionnel au
conseil des ministres mais il y
assistera
il jouera très certainement un rôle
aussi important de faire le lien entre
le bureau du premier ministre et le
caucus il est semble-t-il de bons
conseils pour les députés surtout les
plus jeunes
ça c'est notre collègue paul ça n'a rien
à voir il n'est pas député les
journalistes sont derrière notre
collègue également qui maintenant
travail à la bbc voilà donc ça se met en
place mais ce chariot qui va les prendre
sa place est également incertain un
exercice qui est réglé au quart de tour
là maintenant l' angoisse a été au cours
des derniers jours pour monsieur legault
mais selon vos informations mastin hier
vers us hier vers 16h 17h c'est pas mal
réglé cette histoire là pas mal réglée
willy à rester il reste encore quelques
faits l'attaché mais oui c'était en fin
de journée les choses étaient pas mal
réglée en soirée ya eu quelques
téléphones
surtout pour ceux qui n'avaient pas été
choisis à qui on voulait donner quelques
affectation la matrice je vais vous
quitter parce que je vais aller à la
radio pour l'émission spéciale je vous
retrouve dans à peu près 45 minutes
c'est très bien mais celle ci haut je
dois vous attendre à lisier merci on se
revoit tout à l'heure martin et patrice
c'est ici on voit des députés ici non
non non je vais être avec vous a
violemment
si vous voyez des députés actuellement
sur les images qu'on vous présente c'est
qu'ils ne sont pas ministres les députés
qui n'ont pas accédé au conseil des
ministres sont réunis dans ce salon
rouge ce qu'ils sont ministres sont dans
l'antichambre du salon rouge qu'on
appelle le bureau de la présidence et
ils feront leur entrée un à un par la
suite donc si vous comme donald martel
convoi avec les lunettes là à l'avant
plan c'est l'ancien whip de la coalition
avenir québec ça pourrait faire partie
des déçus des gens qui pensaient qu'ils
pourraient accéder à un poste de
ministre et qui n'ont pas été ministre
monsieur martel donc et dans la foule
ça veut dire qu'il n'accède pas au
conseil des ministres je veux parler
d'un ministre parce que l'on l'a dit
hier jean françois roberge à l'éducation
sébastien pendant qu'on a une minute
avant le début de cette cérémonie
c'est très rare qu'un enseignant lui a
été douze enseignants
pas très loin ici il
il a écrit un livre sur l'école nouvelle
il sera maintenant la tête du ministère
de l'éducation il ya quelque chose de
bien et on attend entre dans le milieu
de l'éducation
les attentes sont élevées sont grandes
oui d'autant que la coalition du québec
a été très critique de ce qui s'est
passé dans le milieu de l'éducation avec
la rigueur ou l'austérité budgétaire du
gouvernement donc les attentes sont
élevées en montagne a pas de baguette
magique on manque d'enseignants la
promesse de la coalition avenir québec
c'est d'instaurer la maternelle quatre
ans pour tous les enfants de 4 ans au
québec d'ici cinq ans c'est un immense
défi parce que d'abord faut construire
des classes dans des écoles où on manque
de place
actuellement pour rénover certaines
écoles il faut engager des enseignants
ou des gens qui s'occuperont de ses
enfants de 4 ans
là le programme la coalition bois québec
c'est de ne pas engager de des
enseignants diplômés de l'université
mais des gens qui auraient des cours
d'éducateur en garderie par exemple avec
une formation d'appoint pour s'occuper
de ses enfants dans la maternelle quatre
ans mais c'est un immense défi est en
effet la caq a tellement vendu sa
réforme du système d'éducation que les
attentes sont très élevées
mais peut-être que les ressources
manquent en tout cas à court terme pour
réaliser ses promesses
il est 14 heures 20 vu cette belle
horloge dans le salon rouge de
l'assemblée nationale donc dans quelques
minutes mesdames et messieurs va
commencer cette cérémonie
d'assermentation des 26 ministres de ce
nouveau gouvernement de la caos à lui
lui les bains louise fait longtemps
qu'il est déçu il a dû il a dû laisser
sa place l'ancien lui il a été
extrêmement important dans la naissance
de ce mouvement là sébastien
oui et c'est un des postes et panneaux
bouillonnec donc sur la gauche
c'est un des penseurs de la première
heure de la colle sur n'y a qu'avec un
allié de la première heure une bonne
partie du programme de la coalition ni à
québec pendant qu'il fait l'accolade je
pense que c'est à lise lavallée qui est
une des députés où s émeut dames la
balle et une et député la d'épisodes
député de repentigny pour la corruption
du québec depuis la première heure il
est aux côtés de monsieur legault dans
cette création dans cette progression
dans cette formation de la coalition
avenir québec etc à tout prix vraiment
pour qu'il quitte le navire
on a fait de lui dans certains siècle
prêteur sur gages se dire à la tête
d'une entreprise ou participants une
entreprise qui faisait des prêts avec
des taux d'intérêt extrêmement élevés
qui n'aurait pas été accepté au québec
notamment il a dû se retirer donc alors
c'est normal d'une certaine façon qui
soit la même si sa carrière politique
n'a jamais vraiment décollé qu'il a dû
se retirer subitement de la campagne
électorale il était remplacé
rappelez-vous par christian lévesque
donc au change monsieur legault a pas
nécessairement perdu ici il a trouvé son
président du conseil du trésor
ça a été extrêmement douloureux
d'ailleurs dans un long texte facebook
qui il reprochait un peu d'avoir été
lâchés et donc mais monsieur legault
c'est cette histoire là ne l'avait pas
s'effacer et avant les débats voulait
peut-être aussi en tout cas c'est bien
tombé
mettre ça de côté mais c'était difficile
je pense pour monsieur legault de se
séparer de monsieur le bouillonnec parce
qu'ils avaient travaillé tellement
étroitement au cours des dernières
années que la déchirure a été dur c'est
pour ça qu'il s'est accroché il a
présenté comme candidat malgré ces
informations qui circulaient à son
endroit mais à un moment donné s'est
aperçu que ça pouvait devenir un boulet
pour la campagne électorale et la
politique c'est ça ça peut être cruel
malgré les amitiés malgré la proximité
monsieur legault a décidé de larguer
stéphane le bouillonnec en cours d'eau
alors sébastien revenons donc à la
formation de ce conseil des ministres 26
6 me mais est ce qu'il aurait pu en
nommer - parce que si le rêve de nouveau
premier ministre
on l'a dit un peu plus tôt il jonglait
avec tête un peu moins mais on
s'aperçoit que ça devient un casse tête
insoluble la réalité rattrape parfois
les ambitions et en effet moi je comme
laisse entendre c'est qu'il a été déjoué
d'une certaine façon par le fait qu'il
avait 74 députés
il s'attendait pas en avoir autant donc
la promesse du conseil des ministres à
une vingtaine de députés est plus près
du wincq du 30 évidemment découlait de
prévision que la coalition bois québec
sur un gouvernement majoritaire certes
mais à moins de 70 depuis hier comme
vous en avez 74 déjà vous avez de la
pression pour élargir les rangs du
conseil des ministres et
la réalité a rattrapé monsieur le gauche
pose sur la première que l'on veut on a
parlé tout à l'heure oui oui qui
n'excédera pas aux côtés des ministres
anciens du spvm
quand vous avez 74 députés ça met la
pression pour grossir les rangs du
conseil des ministres quand vous voulez
la parité homme-femme aussi que vous
avez trente huit femmes sur les 74 28
femmes pendant sur les 74
il ya des choix que vous devez faire et
parfois ça fait en sorte que vous pouvez
juste pas avoir être à la hauteur de
l'ambition vous aviez ou en premier lieu
mais vous devez élargir votre côté des
mises oui exactement
pour questions régionales en femme et
c'est le nombre de facteurs et est assez
important je reviens sur monsieur la
première une seconde monsieur la
première c'est pas le genre d'être déçu
beaucoup pour lui c'est une nouvelle
expérience politique qui commence puis
je pense qu'ils peuvent pas en chine
prendre un peu d'expérience comme député
d'abord puis en verre ensuite avec
quelqu'un au sujet monsieur la première
m'a dit 'il n'est pas en boule dans un
coin chez lui alors même si on ne l'a
pas choisie pour conseil des ministres
il aura peut-être un mandat spécial ou
un autre mandat que lui conférant
monsieur legault puis stoppé sa carte
vous êtes un nouveau venu en politique
vous pouvez peut-être avoir dit
s'attendre quand vous avez la notoriété
de monsieur la première en même temps
vous comprenez probablement si vous êtes
un joueur d'équipé que vous pouvez
devoir céder le pas des gens qui sont là
depuis plus longtemps que peut-être
profil qui correspond un peu mieux au
poste qui sont disponibles dans
l'appareil gouvernement là la première
décision de monsieur legault b bien sûr
c'est d'avoir choisi les 26 ans 8
conseils des mines et ce à 17 heures ce
soir
on veut montrer que le gouvernement va
se mettre rapidement au travail
oui et ça c'est évidemment dans la
relation publique parce qu'il n'y a pas
grande décision qui sera prise je
pensais ce premier conseil des ministres
mais ça va nous permettre d'entrer nous
à l'intérieur de voir donc aussi un
souvent intéressant de voir qui est
assis à côté de qui parce que ça
démontre des affinités entre certains
des ministres
et ça permet de voir qu'ils supportent
pied à l'intérieur du conseil des
ministres cela étant dit s'ils se
décident pas grand chose à ce conseil
des ministres ce soir les ministres vont
avoir d'énormes devoirs à faire à partir
d'aujourd'hui revient avec des cahiers
de charges
dossiers qui sont extrêmement volumineux
et ils vont devoir faire de la lecture
parfois de la lecture rapide subir des
briefings techniques aussi de la part de
leurs fonctionnaires ils ont beau
vouloir réformer aussi certains des
ministres ce qui se passe dans leur
ministère
ils vont s'apercevoir des fois qu'il se
butte à la résistance ou à la protection
naturelle que se fait la fonction
publique à certains égards donc il ya un
lien de confiance à établir également
avec la fonction publique
la plupart y arrive évidemment il n'ya
pas nécessairement de la résistance mais
disons qu'à une période d'adaptation
pour tout le monde
prenons les deux exemples les deux
ministères qui touche le plus les gens
qui nous écoutent éducation santé la
machine de la santé est énorme la madame
mais cannes connaît bien sûr parce
qu'elle a été aussi à montréal à l'
agence de santé mais quand même
avant de comprendre les rouages mais de
sa voix rauque est ici si je pousse trop
fort de scotty s'ils y arrivent ceci
cela ça prend un certain temps et c'est
une machine qui est blessé on a
l'impression avec les années de guetta
barrette les la rigueur l'austérité les
conséquences que ça a eu le style de
gestion peut-être de monsieur barrette
il est arrivé sain faut le lui rendent à
certains résultats monsieur barrette il
a augmenté par exemple la prise en
charge des médecins de famille diminuer
un peu le temps d'attentes mais disons
qu'on a l'impression que le système de
santé a subi les conséquences de la
rigueur d'austérité budgétaire ces
dernières années alors dans quel état
d'esprit est il comme un malade mais
cannes va aborder cette relation avec le
système de santé
rappelez vous que la caq veut rouvrir
l'entente avec les médecins spécialistes
aussi mais c'est maintenant ils
attendent d'avoir le l'étude sur la
comparaison salariale avec l'horizon une
petite année de vol
c'est ça mais c'est cette volonté
annoncée pourrait amener du sable dans
l'engrenage aussi les médecins
omnipraticiens sont dans la mire de la
coalition en irak québec irait pour les
gens qui n'étaient pas avec nous plutôt
un homme brun l'épousé du premier
ministre
on qui a toujours eu ce rôle très très
présent elle aime la politique mène en
bresse l'épreuve ce n'est pas ce n'est
pas une tâche pour elle qui est
difficile d'aller parler aux gens
d'aller tenter de les convaincre alors
voilà remplissement énorme pour elles
oui parce que qu'on le veuille ou non
les conjoints conjointe des politiciens
les accompagne dans cette démarche a
dans cette quête de pouvoir dans le cas
de monsieur legault qui se concrétise
aujourd'hui et font les sacrifices liés
à la vie politique
monsieur legault il est pas souvent à la
maison il se promène un peu partout au
québec il s'ils agissaient à l'assemblée
nationale et à partir d'aujourd'hui ou
devient premier ministre
il sera encore moins à la maison alors
il ya un sacrifice que les familles font
autour autour des politiciens juste pour
terminer sur la machine de la santé par
exemple
c'est un peu comme quand vous avez un
nouveau patron qui arrive au travail
ici c'est une nouvelle ministre qui
arrivent tous les employés vont observer
le nouveau patron pour voir dans quelle
direction il va et il y aura une période
d'adaptation aux six éoliennes confiance
à établir tout à fait ça peut être plus
ou moins longs dépendant du talent de
gestionnaires de chacun des dix
ministres nommés mais madame mais cannes
veut en tout cas insuffler une vraie
menace pas difficile parce que rencontre
assez vide entre le ciel des deux entre
tubes arrêt depuis madame mais chalmé
veut insuffler un espèce d'apaisement
dans le système qui ont été choqués
certains diront avec raison il fallait
procéder à certains chocs et de synthés
trouvé là un débat qu'on règle rapport
ensemble maintenant en tout cas est
différent s'il puis à une promesse
on en a parlé un peu plus tôt aux
urgences bien sûr qu'il a quatre ans
pour le faire mais 90 minutes d'attentes
aux urgences c'est une énorme bouche et
apprendre et c'est quoi c'est l'hôpital
juif à montréal c'est ça qui est qui qui
qui tourne autour de 95 90 minutes mais
ils ont tout refait leur système à cet
endroit là ce qu'on sera capable de
recréer ça partout en question et le
discours des libéraux depuis quatre ans
était de dieye assez d'argent dans le
système ce une question d'organisation
du système
on a forcé les médecins de famille par
exemple apprendre plus de patients on a
ouvert des groupes de médecine de
famille qui sont ouverts plus longtemps
plus de jours également pour
diriger les gens vers ses médecins de
famille plutôt que vers les urgences des
hôpitaux par exemple il ya comme quelque
chose par contre qui est pas encore
assimilé pour la population qui continue
d'aller vers les urgences alors il ya un
travail de pédagogie d'éducation à faire
mais il ya aussi peut-être les
ressources à déployer de façon plus
efficace dans le réseau de la santé
c'est un travail qui n'est peut-être pas
encore très bien d'ailleurs d'accord on
parlera très rapidement à la nouvelle
ministre la santé qui va aller oui vous
avez vu il y avait quelqu'un à côté de
madame bret qui levait la main je pense
que c'est martin koskinen con qu'on voit
pas souvent qui est un homme de l'ombre
le chef de cabinet de monsieur monsieur
legault et qui a été au coeur des
décisions qui sont prises aujourd'hui
c'est martin koskinen qui a mené la
transition gouvernementale entre les
libéraux et la coalition bois québec qui
a géré aussi le conseil des ministres et
me dit on qui gère aussi les déçus et
des déceptions de ce qui aujourd'hui
n'entendront pas leur nom résonner dans
le salon rouge de l'assemblée nationale
c'est peut-être le poste le plus
important avec celui de premier
secrétaire
donc le premier fonctionnaire qui a été
nommé également mais martin koskinen
aura sur ses épaules toute la gestion du
bureau du premier ministre et un ancien
chef de cabinet de jean chrétien jean
pelletier un homme de québec qu'il
décide est maintenant me disais c'est
comme une horlogerie un bureau de
premier ministre
puis il faut vraiment que chaque
personne sache exactement quelle est sa
taille et à quel moment la faire alors
ce sera le lattage de koskinen
d'autant plus qu'on n'a pas le temps du
temps maintenant dans l'est avec les
médias sociaux avec les médias 24 heures
de donner une première impression de
gouvernement la route fois les lunes de
miel ces six mois puis je regardais seul
matin dans les journaux
là aussi c'est rapide et la première
impression sera rapide ou si oui d'où le
défi des communications 1 et ça c'est
très présent dans la réflexion de
monsieur legault pour les premiers pas
de son gouvernement
il veut bien communiquer il ne veut pas
faire d'erreur et
rappelez vous y depuis deux semaines il
ya des affirmations très forte qui sont
faites par les porte-paroles de la
transition
nous allons présenter un projet de loi
sur la laïcité rapidement les gens qui
refusent d'enlever leurs signes
religieux qui sont en situation
d'autorité pourraient perdre leur emploi
et on va aller rapidement sur certains
dossiers on va prendre notre temps sur
d'autres
donc on veut que le message soit bien
cadré peut-être qu'on a pris des leçons
de la campagne électorale aussi et on
veut bien faire les choses et bien
communiquer aux québécois pour qu'on
comprenne le message de la can
exactement je vous rappelle mesdames et
messieurs un peu de retard c'est normal
le temps que tous ces gens là prennent
leur place ave c pas mal fait il ya
beaucoup moins de mouvements au salon
rouge on le dit à l'extérieur que tout
le monde tous les invités sont
maintenant entré alors dans quelques
secondes
re minute vous ne les voyez pas encore
les mini fiction derrière et à tour de
rôle ils vont entrer le premier ministre
monsieur legault va entrer en premier
évidemment et ce sera comme ça à la
suite un après l'autre qui prêteront
serment et qui viendront s'asseoir et
formera ainsi l'hérault la photo de
famille de ce premier conseil des
ministres on va écouter justement la
dame va nous donner du rêve
soyez les bienvenus dans la salle du
conseil législatif de l'hôtel du
parlement
à l'occasion de la cérémonie de
prestation de serment des membres du
conseil des ministres veuillez je vous
prie vous lever afin d'accueillir son
honneur le lieutenant gouverneur du
québec l'honorable j michel doyon
[Applaudissements]
mais accueillons maintenant le député de
l'assomption et premier ministre du
québec monsieur françois legault
c'était sa mère mesdames et messieurs
bien sûr ceux qui n'étaient pas avec
nous avant sa mère très fier de son fils
voilà
[Applaudissements]
j'invite maintenant monsieur le
lieutenant gouverneur du québec à
prendre la parole monsieur le premier
ministre désigné monsieur françois
legault madame bray mesdames et
messieurs les députés
monsieur le secrétaire général du
gouvernement distingue les invités
mesdames et messieurs je vous dirais que
c'est avec honneur et fierté qu'il m'ait
donné aujourd'hui de présider cette
cérémonie
non seulement importante et marquant
mais surtout mémorable pour beaucoup de
gens qui sont ici aujourd'hui
le premier devoir est le plus important
de war du lieutenant-gouverneur en vertu
du système politique qui est nôtre et
celui de veiller à ce que le
gouvernement soit toujours redevable
envers les élus c'est à dire qu'il
s'agisse d'un gouvernement responsable
la nomination du premier ministre et sur
la vie de ce dernier
celle d'un membre du cabinet qu'il
constitue le conseil exécutif sont donc
en tête de liste des responsabilités du
lieutenant-gouverneur usage veut que le
chef du parti ayant remporté une
majorité de sièges lors d'une élection
générale soit désigné à titre de premier
ministre et ce après la démission du
titulaire précédent et ce jusqu à
l'assermentation du nouveau premier
ministre et de son cabinet
suivant le principe que l'état ne doit
jamais être sans gouvernement
or le premier ministre couillard
m'informait de 11 octobre dernier qu'il
entendait quitter ses fonctions
premier ministre du québec et de
président du conseil exécutif au jour et
à l'heure de l'assermentation du nouveau
premier ministre et de son cabinet nous
y voilà donc c'est donc avec beaucoup de
joie mais avec une certaine émotion que
je m'apprête à exercer ce devoir en
assénant un resserrement à monsieur
françois legault à titre de nouveau
premier ministre du québec et par la
suite relais membres qui l'a désigné
pour former le nouveau conseil des
ministres
les fonctions quel numéro qu'elle cache
humeur ont dorénavant monsieur legault à
titre de premier ministre
les membres du conseil exécutif de même
que les membres de l'assemblée nationale
sont d'une grande importance au sein de
nos sociétés démocratiques et du québec
il est de notre devoir de citoyen qui
que nous soyons de remercier ces femmes
et ces hommes quelle que soit leur
allégeance
quel que soit notre allégeance et qui
conscients de leurs devoirs sociaux
consacrent une grande partie de leur vie
au fait d'aller au mieux être du bien
public
le but de tout engagement politique il
ne faut jamais l'oublier et celui d'agir
en vue du bien commun aussi leur
dévouement et leur effort mais dit elle
notre plus grand respect un nouveau
gouvernement s'apprête aujourd'hui à
prendre les affaires la direction des
affaires de l'état
ces femmes et ces hommes qui seront
appelés un enfer parties auront
l'immense privilège de jouer un rôle de
première importance
quant au devenir du québec de demain
elle
et ils peuvent en être fiers mais il ne
faut pas oublier en contrepartie est que
celle-ci sera des plus exigeantes
compte tenu de toutes les
responsabilités qui leur incombent
auront dorénavant qui seront leurs
désormais je tiens donc à féliciter
monsieur françois lebon premier ministre
du québec domaine que les ministres sera
entièrement et sous peu et leur
souhaiter tout le succès espéré dans
l'exercice du pouvoir dont l'essence
même je le soulignais tout à l'air est
le mieux être de la population et de la
collectivité québécoise
j'inviterais donc monsieur françois
legault député de la circonscription de
la sanction à venir me rejoindre en vue
de prêter serment à titre de premier
ministre du québec monsieur legault
monsieur premier ministre
je françois legault d'éclat sous serment
que je remplirai les devoirs de ma
charge de membres du conseil exécutif
avec honnêteté et justice et que je ne
ferai connaître sans diète dûment
autorisées quoi que ce soit dangereux
réu connaissance dans l'exercice de ma
charge jeu françois legault déclare sous
serment que je remplirai les devoirs de
ma charge de premier ministre avec
honnêteté et justice
[Applaudissements]
2e premier me laisse du québec
nous signons un contrat
beaucoup de fierté sentiment
d'accomplissement pas de triomphalisme
sébastien le second le 5 ce traitement
émue fière 32e premier ministre il a
réussi ce pari là de sortir le québec de
ces deux partis traditionnels parti
québécois parti libéral du puy en
cinquante dernières années il a réussi à
amener avec lui des fédéralistes et
souverainistes et à former une coalition
justement la coalition avenir québec est
là le travail commence mais pour
l'instant avec sa mère s'est dit un peu
plus tôt à véronique ne changera pas sa
mère qui est fier de lui alors
évidemment on l'a vu souffler
c'est de l'émotion mais les membres du
conseil des ministres
vous seront présentés monsieur
jean-françois provençal chef de cabinet
et secrétaire particulier du
lieutenant-gouverneur procédera à
l'appel de chaque personne invitée à en
faire partie chaque futur ministre
prêtera le ou les serments d' usage
devant le secrétaire général et greffier
du gouvernement il signera ensuite le
registre des serments et affirmation
solennelle des membres du conseil des
ministres du québec en présence du
lieutenant gouverneur sans plus tarder
je cède la parole à jean françois
provençal
vice première ministre ministre de la
sécurité publique ministre responsable
de la région de la capitale nationale
madame geneviève guilbaud gérard
guilbaut vice première ministre ministre
de la sécurité publique c'est énorme
comme tâche c'est vrai ebooks avait
parti le bal lors d'une partielle dans
louis-hébert en 2017
elle symbolise le renouveau du parti et
elle symbolise la victoire surtout de ce
parti est de 35 ans et leur a en plus de
la responsabilité de ministre de la
sécurité publique et vice-première
ministre la responsabilité d'être le
ministre responsable de la
capitale-nationale donc c'est elle qui
va faire affaire avec monsieur labeaume
notamment
je
c'est ma fille geneviève guilbaud
déclare sous serment que je remplirai
les devoirs de ma charge de membres du
conseil exécutif avec honnêteté et
justice et que je ne ferai connaître
sans y être dûment autorisée
quoi que ce soit dont j'aurais eu
connaissance dans l'exercice de ma
charge
je juge une vieille guilbaud déclare
sous serment que je remplirai les
devoirs de ma charge de ministre de la
sécurité publique et de ministre
responsable de la région de la capitale
nationale avec honnêteté et justice
qu'elle a dit sébastien mesdames et
messieurs que c'était sa petite fille
qu'on attendait plus sainement
elle s'appelle capucine et les terrans
set lorsqu'elle a été élue dans une
élection partielle dans la
circonscription de louis hébert
elle a accouché par la suite en cours de
mandat et s'est retiré à peine quelques
jours ou si je me rappelle bien et elle
a été réélue donc dans la
circonscription de louis hébert la
sécurité publique c'est un ministère où
elle a déjà travaillé
madame guilbaud elle était porte parole
de la sécurité civile rappelé voit une
certaine époque on l'a notamment
beaucoup vu dans la tragédie du à lac
mégantic le déraillement de train et
elle donnait le point presse quotidien
de la sécurité civile à ce moment là est
un peu avant elle avait également été
attachée de presse adjointe du ministre
libéral de la sécurité publique à
l'époque où autour des années 2005 qui
était sous ministre à la sécurité
publique à l'époque c'était jacques
dupuis donc il avait frayé un peu avec
les libéraux avant de devenir
fonctionnaires et de devenir par la
suite député de la pollution des évêques
dans la région qui symbolise bien
justement sans coalition
ok monsieur le ministre de l'éducation
et de l'enseignement supérieur
monsieur jean françois roberge 12 ans
dans des salles de cours connaît bien
les salles de cours où monsieur robert
devient ministre de l'éducation il avait
écrit ne relie donc sûr ici ont
réinventé les colts en 2016 alors
connaît bien l aviez la base qu'elle
aime bien le métier et dans le milieu de
l'éducation le disent un peu plus tôt ça
sera certainement très très très bien
accueilli et avoir des l'art autrement
dit à la tête de ce ministère très
important vous étiez pas
je jean françois roberge d'éclat sous
serment que je remplirai les devoirs de
ma charge de membres du conseil exécutif
avec honnêteté et justice et que je ne
ferai connaître sans y être dûment
autorisée
quoi que ce soit dont je leur ai eu
connaissance dans l'exercice de ma
charge jeu jean françois roberge les
classes sous serment que je remplirai
les devoirs de ma charge de ministre de
l'éducation et de l'enseignement
supérieur avec honnêteté et justice
c'est à sa base et de le gars à qui
d'enseigner pendant 17 ans au niveau
primaire donc un michel roberge connaît
bien il est a fait apprécier dans le
caucus au sport oui très apprécié dans
le caucus gars qui qui est rigoureux qui
a tiré son épingle joue aussi dans les
débats parlementaires trop facile il
était opposé à sébastien proulx un des
ars du parti libéral notez qu'il est à
la fois ministre de l'éducation et de
l'enseignement supérieur
c'était c'était sous les libéraux hills
où les péquistes aussi sauf erreur deux
ministères c'est un ministère de
l'éducation dont pour le primaire le
secondaire est un ministère de
l'enseignement supérieur pour le
collégial et l'universitaire lui il
regroupe tout ça a donc il en appelait
son assiette avec la mission que lui
confie
monsieur legault notamment l'abolition
des commissions scolaires ou sur le
thème oublier en cours de route sa part
et le remplacement de transformer le
monde amassé transformer wayne par delhi
remplacé don par des centres de service
et la maternelle 4 ans partout sinon
madame isabelle charest
dallier allait épouser abel charest
délégué du gabon missisquoi il alors
[Applaudissements]
je isabelle charest déclare sous serment
que je remplirai les devoirs de ma
charge demande du conseil exécutif avec
honnêteté et justice et que je ne ferai
connaître sans y être dûment autorisée
quoi que ce soit dont j'aurais eu
connaissance dans l'exercice de ma
charge
je lisais belchard et déclare sous
serment que je remplirai les devoirs de
ma charge de ministre délégué à
l'éducation avec honnêteté et justice
alors très premier d'ailleurs et je
deviens patinage de vitesse évidemment
est la particule jeux olympiques de 94
98 2002 elle était chef de mission de la
délégation canadienne lors du dernier
jules d'ailleurs oui et s'occupera des
loisirs et du sport selon ce que je
comprends c'est légal éducation ou est
déléguée à l'éducation si jamais en
charge du secteur loisirs et sports
c'était sauf erreur le ministère de
l'éducation du loisir et des sports sous
les libéraux donc loisirs et sports
incombe donc à sept ministres délégués
qui est madame charest c'était une des
candidatures vedette dans la grande
région d'esprit enfin l'esprit quand on
est si on veut là ou en partie on
pensait que l'élection se jouerait et là
où la coalition avenir québec donc a
fait une belle percée lors du des
élections du 1er octobre
ça a été vraiment une recrue importante
seront ici le bon ça donne un visage
aussi
moderne
comme chef de mission elle s'est frottée
à l'administration aussi à la gestion
ministre de l'économie et de
l'innovation ministre responsable de la
région de lanaudière ne s'obtient fils
ben ça c'est intégration caire fait de
brenco la lettre dans le trio économique
de ce gouvernement nous les eaux
l'économie de l'innovation
pourquoi le premier trio de l'économie
parce que les quêtes économique est
large mais bien qu'il fait partie du
premier polonais
de ces jeux pierre fait grève déclare
sous serment que je remplirai les
devoirs de ma charge de membres du
conseil exécutif avec honnêteté justice
et que je ne ferai connaître sans y être
dûment autorisée
quoi que ce soit dont j'aurais eu
connaissance dans l'exercice de ma
charge jeu pierre fitzgibbon déclare
sous serment que je remplir les devoirs
de ma charge de ministre de l'économie
de l'innovation et de ministre
responsable de la région de lanaudière
avec honnêteté justice député de
terrebonne sebastian à l'intervention
donc c'était un château-fort pis qu'ils
sont une exception de mecs à 2008 le
maire c'est un homme d'affaires
financier et les proches de monsieur
legault absolument il se côtoient sur
l'utile à l'extérieur de leur activité
professionnelle chacun et il aura un
mandat extrêmement complexe celui de
réformer investissement québec françois
legault chouette que investissement
québec investisse différement dans
l'économie du québec soutiennent plus
peut-être la petite et moyenne
entreprise enfin il y à une réforme
d'investissement québec qui s'en
viennent
on le décrit comme un véritable
gentleman d'où ce titre ibr on verra
donc quel genre de fois il ne peut avoir
pour réformer
avec ce matin
ministre délégué au développement
économique régional ministre responsable
de la région de la chaudière appalaches
de la région du bas-saint-laurent et de
la région de la gaspésie îles de la
madeleine
madame ariège au
c'est le deuxième cercle dans vos pas
renié doit l'équipe économie oui ça
c'est une candidature
ce n'était pas femme et les personnes
qu'on voyait venir comment un train au
conseil des ministres mais elle a été
élue dans la circonscription de côte du
sud c'est la région de montmagny et
paraît que c'est une candidature quand
même très bonne conneries yves proulx
déclare sous serment que je remplirai
les devoirs de ma charge de membres du
conseil exécutif avec honnêteté et
justice et que je ne ferai connaître
sans y être dûment autorisée
quoi que ce soit dont j'aurais eu
connaissance dans l'exercice 2010 charge
je marie ève coup d'éclat sous serment
que je remplirai les devoirs de ma
charge de ministre délégué au
développement économique régional et de
ministre responsable de la région de la
chaudière appalaches de la région du
bas-saint-laurent de la région de la
gaspésie des îles de la madeleine avec
honnêteté et justice qu'elle a été mais
reste de mise parti de saint pierre de
rivière du sud mais elle s'est
développée donc une carrière en gestion
est essentielle
et si elle accumule les postes de
ministre régional c'est que au delà de
rivière du loup dont vers l'est en
gaspésie la coalition avenir québec n'a
fait élire aucun député sur la côte-nord
au delà de en fait au delà du de la
rivière saguenay au delà de tadoussac la
coalition de québec n'a fait élire aucun
député alors elle cumule des fonctions
de ministre régional pour aussi région
de gaspé de la gaspésie et si j'ai bien
compris de la connais je vais juste
vérifier au moment où je vous parle
c'est pas inscrits ou jusque sur le
document que j'ai peut-être oui
forcément parce qu'à moins craint donc
un don
hélas hélas deux trois postes de
ministres régionales parce que justement
la corruption d'un québec n'a pas réussi
à accéder à certaines régions du québec
dont elle va devoir cumuler les postes
de ministre régional
c'est son premier mandat pour ceux qui
se posent la question donc pour ceux qui
n'y ont pas comme monsieur eric girard
on s'était vraiment intérêt graphique un
bon bilan le sujet racle se retrouve aux
finances allemand et portant le poste de
les étudiants s'y était trésorier d'un
bal national depuis 2011 gros poste à la
banque nationale il avait décidé de
faire le saut en politique je eric
girard des classes sous serment que je
remplirai les devoirs de ma charge de
membres du conseil exécutif avec un été
et justice et que je ne ferai connaître
sans y être dûment autorisée
quoi que ce soit dont j'aurais eu
connaissance dans l'exercice de ma
charge jeu eric scheer a déclaré sous
serment que je remplirai les devoirs de
ma charge de ministre des finances et de
ministre responsable de la région de
laval avec honnêteté et justice tu
verras qu'il ne sera pas ne vous
attendez pas un militant très très
partisan le sujet sera d'ailleurs dans
la première conférence de presse
oui j'aurais plus peut-être dans une
autre vie est libéral mais là je trouve
que la coalition avenir québec et est en
meilleure posture et j'aime leur
proposition connaît monsieur legault
également très bien il ya une relation
de confiance entre les deux hommes
donc ce sera un des piliers de ce
nouveau gouvernement évidemment et il
était à l'origine la plateforme
financière économique de la coalition
née à québec c'est pas une bourde de
charisme nécessairement monsieur girard
s'est probablement pas le meilleur
communicateur du gouvernement mais on le
dit rigoureux donc dans la façon dont il
fait les choses et c'est la raison pour
laquelle avait ni s'est lancé en
politique je pense pourrait être mieux
des finances que vérité bon joint ce
n'avait pas été nommée la maison qu il
avait ce ministère en tête
je m'auto corrige pour vous dire que
marie ève coup la pierre qu'on a vu il
ya quelques instants sur un mini ce
responsable de chaudière appalaches bas
saint laurent et la région de la
gaspésie-îles-de-la-madeleine donc elle
couvrira booster la santé et des
services sociaux madame danielle mais
cannes c'est un visage que les québécois
vont apprendre à connaître beaucoup
ramlakan qui hérite de cette importante
pour ja difficile presque casse-gueule
j'allais dire ministère de la santé au
québec
les attentes sont énormes le lan local
c'est une recrue car en place filmo mais
qui est devenu c'est une des étoiles de
cette équipe de monsieur legault avec
son calme ecoutons-la une seconde jeu
daniel mais kahn déclaré sous serment
que je remplirai les devoirs de ma
charge de membres du conseil exécutif
avec honnêteté et justice et que je ne
ferai connaître sans y être dûment
autorisée
quoi que ce soit dont j'aurais eu
connaissance dans l'exercice de ma
charge jeu daniel mais kahn déclare sous
serment que je rentre et les devoirs de
ma charge de ministre de la santé et des
services sociaux avec honnêteté et
justice ancien pdg donc de l' agence de
la santé et des services sociaux de
montréal alain six ans jusqu'à sa
sanction en politique avec monsieur
nebout elle a remplacé gertrude bourdon
sébastien au pied levé et monsieur
legault l'avait avait pas fait de
cachette à dire voici ma nouvelle
ministre l'a senti si on est élu avec un
mandat important de réduire le temps
d'attenté aux urgences à 90 minutes de
s'assurer que toutes les ressources dans
le réseau de la santé sont vieilles
déployer et de revoir les ententes avec
les [ __ ] les fédérations de médecins
omnipraticiens et spécialistes pour
peut-être aller chercher de l'argent qui
pourraient être réinvestis dans le
système de santé donc être ministre de
la santé c'est un set
mandat extrêmement important et très
difficile et si vous me permettez on a
une réaction de pascal bérubé le nouveau
chef parlementaire du parti québécois
sur la nomination de madame trou comme
ministre régional pour la région du bas
saint laurent et de la gaspésie il dit
une même ministre pour trois régions
point d'interrogation manque de
considération du nouveau gouvernement à
l'égard du bas-saint-laurent de la
gaspésie
monsieur lionel carmant notamment
l'achat d'un dessus le bon lionel
carmant très présent durant cette
campagne le site est souvent un
neurologue depuis 20 ans et spécialisée
en épilepsie lady l'été directeur de
neurologie au chu sainte justine
monsieur qu'armand donc que monsieur
legault est allé chercher pour s'occuper
entre autres de la petite enfance de la
liste déléguer certains services sociaux
jeu lionel carmant déclare sous serment
que je remplirai les devoirs de ma
charge de membres du conseil exécutif
avec honnêteté et justice et que je ne
ferai connaître sans être dûment
autorisée
quoi que ce soit dont j'aurais eu
connaissance dans l'exercice de ma
charge
je viens incarnant déclare sous serment
que je remplirai les devoirs de ma
charge de ministre délégué à la santé et
aux services sociaux avec honnêteté et
justice pis si d'anciens de culte ou des
bulles qu'armand à travailler tout seul
donc il était à contribuer aux mêmes
fins fondateur de la cac
donc c'est un cas qu'est-ce que de
longue date et un proche de françois
legault
on le décrit sans aucune malice une soit
monsieur qu'armand anversois se trouer
le mode à qu'on lui confie c'est de
s'assurer de du dépistage notamment des
problèmes que peuvent avoir les enfants
en bas âge pour leur permettre d'avoir
un parcours scolaire qui sera productif
qu'il va leur permettre d'aller au bout
de leurs études
plutôt que de les perdre en route
peut-être avec une préoccupation
particulière pour les gars qui sont
parfois mis en marge du 7e colère ou qui
scolaire ou qui décroche plus facilement
donc ce sera la mission de monsieur
clairement quand on parle de petite
enfance top sales dépistage précoce
notamment
des problèmes pour ces enfants-là jour
une petite parenthèse pour vous dire que
la dernière fois qu'il ya eu une
ministre de la santé
selon ce qu'on m'indique là lorsque
madame mais calédonie aujourd'hui
c'était en 2001 avec pauline marois
donc c'est pas souvent qu'il ya des
ministres femmes de la santé ministre
responsable des aînés et des broches
dédain mais dans marguerite blais et
voilà madame blais le soir de la
victoire monsieur legault l'avait
enlacée en disant je vais la voir les
années on avait entendu clairement
qu'elle est revenu en politique pour ça
l'ancien libéral évidemment on le sait
c'est son cinquième mandat à l'assemblée
nationale
un pas constitutive bien sûr les élus en
2007 la première fois et le sujet dont
elle veut parler elle veut faire avancer
la cause des personnes âgées jeu
marguerite blais déclare sous serment
que je remplirai mes devoirs de ma
charge de membres du conseil exécutif
avec honnêteté et justice et que je ne
ferai connaître sans être dûment
autorisée
quoi que ce soit dont j'aurais eu
connaissance dans l'exercice de ma
charge
je marguerite blais d'éclat sous serment
que je remplirai mes devoirs de ma
charge de ministre responsable des aînés
et des projets dans avec honnêteté et
justice unis khomitski aller l'asean
avoir fait partie d'un cabinet minute
par le passé donc dans ce dans ce
nouveau conseil des ministres alors
voilà madame blais qui a eu ce qu'elle
désirait avec amanda probablement
d'implanter à
à moyen long terme ce que monsieur
legault appels mails et maison des aînés
donc de faire des ch et celle des
actuels des milieux de vie a fait
construire de nouveaux ch est cédée en
fait des maisons des aînés ou le milieu
de vie sera plus agréable que dans les
chs et des actuels c'était la grande une
des grandes propositions pour la
coalition du québec lors de cette
campagne électorale et je vous précise
que non seulement il est ministre
responsable des aînés mais également des
proches aidants donc on incorpore à son
titre et à ses fonctions la notion de
prochaine
la particularité rythme à gori des sept
quartiers des sondages sur les
personnalités politiques
elle est toujours première de classe
elle est toujours la plus populaire dans
les sondages parmi les politiciens bien
au-delà de ses collègues ministres
cette préparation mentale et président
du conseil du trésor ministre
responsable de la région de la
montérégie
monsieur christian dubé pense à celles
aux prises en campagne le quart à une
autre régulièrement à important dans
l'histoire s'est déroulée aussi mon dieu
qu'ils sachent des cas accepter de pied
levé de prendre la place de l'ancien
président du parti qui est parti on en
parlait un peu plus tôt à me suis dit tu
viens présente conseil de plusieurs
expériences à marquer ce dépôt avait été
élu à la cape
il avait siégé 2012 à 2014 alors je
christian dubé déclare sur serment que
je remplirai les devoirs de ma charge du
manque de conseillers exécutifs avec
honnêteté et justice et que je ne ferai
connaître sans y être dûment autorisée
quoi que ce soit dont j'aurais eu
connaissance dans l'exercice de ma
charge jeu christian dubé déclare sous
serment que je remplirai les devoirs de
ma charge de ministre responsable de
l'administration gouvernementale et
présidente du conseil du trésor et de
ministre responsable de la région de la
montérégie avec honnêteté et justice
[Applaudissements]
salaire 1 point 150 millions
il a ré embarqué dans ce train là avec
beaucoup de joie et il est maintenant
président du conseil du trésor
vous parliez de soi tout à l'heure pour
monsieur qu'armand quoique j'ai connu le
père de monsieur clairement comme
professeur de mathématiques qui était
une fois mais quand même avec une pointe
derrière mais bref monsieur dubé n'est
pas non plus un personnage qui cherchent
la confrontation
absolument et on le sent consensuel on
sent que il veut convaincre les gens de
la pertinence des propositions qu'il
fait il est là pour gérer les tangos de
la bouche de ce gouvernement et c'est un
poste stratégique c'est à l'ap à sa
porte que tous les ministres collègues
viennent cogner pour obtenir des budgets
de l'argent additionnel
et quand je parlais de la négociation
des ententes avec les médecins en fait
c'est lui qui va devoir mener cette
négociation là beaucoup d'industries de
l'audience des récentes ministre
responsable des relations canadiennes et
de la francophonie canadienne ministre
responsable de la condition féminine
madame sonia lebel sas une autre recrue
cas rapportés d'abord comme conseillère
ou dures ont dû de monsieur legault
n'est après comme candidate dans
champlain bien sûr ministre qu'il vient
miner la justice on a bien bien connu
les québécois rrq à la commission
charbonneau et le procureur-chef la
commission charbonneau ces
interrogatoires qu'on a en tête
comment les oubliez pas devient la
nouvelle
la justice je sonia lebel d'éclat sous
serment que je remplirai les devoirs de
ma charge de membres du conseil exécutif
avec honnêteté et justice et que je ne
ferai connaître sans y être dûment
autorisée
quoi que ce soit dont j'aurais eu
connaissance dans l'exercice de ma
charge jeu sonia lebel d'éclat sous
serment que je remplirai les devoirs de
ma charge
le ministre de la justice ministre
responsable des relations canadiennes et
de la francophonie canadienne et de
ministre responsable de la condition
féminine avec honnêteté et justice la
particularité ce terme n'aura pas en
principe
comines et de la justification cabaye
voire mais la responsabilité d'al aïn
cité mais elle a en revanche d'autres
responsabilités qu'on lui a donné
sébastien madame la ministre de
grand-sault et l'ama d'autorité par
excellence de l'état québécois
les actes les plus solennels ans ont
revêtu je vous remets le grand souk du
québec dont vous êtes la gardienne en
vertu de la loi sur le ministère de la
justice
on la joue dans son carcan éliminait
ajusté sur les gars viennent du grand
show dont la tradition de justice du
gouvernement madame lebel donc est aussi
responsable des relations qu à
l'indienne la francophonie et de la
condition féminine
voilà donc ça fait plusieurs
responsabilités pour madame lebel le
ministre de la justice participent moins
à la joute partisane parce que justement
il est le gardien des sceaux l'equilibre
rentrer dedans dans la lah la justice ou
la dispensation de la justice alors il
ya un aspect particulier à ce rôle de
ministre la justice évidemment comme
ministre responsable des relations
canadiennes et de la francophonie de la
condition féminine elle va peut-être
participer plus souvent aux débats
partisans
c'était le poste qu'elle visait
semble-t-il madame lebel
elle avait de la compétition parce que
simon genin barrette était aussi sur les
rangs
et finalement c'est elle qui est nommé à
ce poste de ministre de la justice elle
a indiqué qu'ils aient cru cités avaient
leur place dans les salles de cours au
québec et à l'assemblée nationale du str
des transports ministre responsable de
la région de l'estrie
monsieur françois bonnardel et quand on
parle donc de la racine a des cuisses la
deûle et de sueur du tout début qui ont
voulu une troisième fois dans voilà un
exemple
bonnardel aucun cas l'important
ministère des transports est énorme et
bien sûr sans éducation
mais les transports c'est un donneur
d'ouvragé gigantesque au québec avec
tous les problèmes que ça te pose est
comment ici
[Applaudissements]
je françois bonnardel déclare sous
serment que je vais remplir les devoirs
de ma charge de membres du conseil
exécutif avec honnêteté justice et que
je ne ferai connaître sans être dûment
autorisée
quoi que ce soit dont j'aurais eu
connaissance dans l'exercice de ma
charge
je françois bonnardel déclare sous
serment que je remplirai les devoirs de
ma charge de ministre des transports et
de ministre responsable de la région de
l'estrie avec un été et justice 5
allemande a obtenu là quelques semaines
il se gardait la racine 50 vraiment su
que l'habitude la voici un bel exemple
et rappelez-vous dans son discours lors
de l'assermentation des députés la
coalition du québec monsieur legault
avait fait allusion aux quatre députés
restants survivants de la cua de
l'action démocratique dont monsieur
bonnardel
il ya aussi marc picard il y à aussi
sébastien schneeberger qui est notre
député delà de l'action démocratique et
eric un an je demandais qu'est ce que ça
allait vouloir dire en termes de
d'accession au conseil des ministres à
une partie de la réponse ici avec
monsieur bonnardel qui hérite comme vous
l'avez dit une fonction importante au
ministère des transports
un mystère qui peut être l'objet de
tentatives d'influencé est un donneur
d'immenses contrat et qui doit être
gérée de façon efficace
beaucoup de défis sur les routes du
québec pour une grande visibilité pour
un minet des transports je suis devant
les caméras ministre responsable de la
métropole et de la région de montréal
madame chantal rouleau
mais voilà madame
le délégué aux transports et responsable
que la métropole c'est une des deux
seuls élus sur l'île de montréal donc
elle passe de mairesse de rivière des
prairies pointe aux trembles à minet
délégué aux transports les responsables
à métropole sera intéressant de voir les
relations éclat la mairesse de montréal
je chantal rouleau des classes sous
serment que je remplirai les devoirs de
ma charge de membres du conseil exécutif
avec honnêteté justice et que je ne
ferai connaître sans y être dûment
autorisée
quoi que ce soit dont j'aurais eu
connaissance dans l'exercice de ma
charge
je chantal rouleau déclare sous serment
que je remplirai les devoirs de ma
charge de ministre délégué aux
transports et de ministre responsable de
la métropole et de la région de montréal
avec honnêteté et justice aille chantal
rouleau d'éclairs en deux autres dates à
charles mayaud fait sauf member of des
conseils exécutifs
on est les angels en data et shore note
disclose on laisse giuly authorized et
knitting date mais comme tout milow
knowledge and child of my duties paille
chantal rouleau d'éclairs en deux autres
dates à charles meyer chief minister for
jansport and minister responsible for de
métropolis de montréal
huit jeunes en est folle et la région du
gorgol de façon honnête et juste
voilà ensuite seulement pourquoi madame
roulons a décidé de le faire également
un anglais adam ashton choix et 2
on présume que la raison principale
c'est que comme étant ministre
responsable de montréal
elle a voulu s'adresser aux montréalais
anglophone également c'est la première
qui l'a fait lors de cette cérémonie
pour l'instant donc madame rouleau qui
sera là en principe jeudi en principe
l'interface entre les le pouvoir
municipal de montréal et le gouvernement
mais il ya des liens en pratique qui se
crée entre la mairie montréal est
directement le bureau du premier
ministre
normalement oui et c'est il ya en
général un assez bon lien de
communication mais la ministre
responsable de la métropole jouera
certainement un rôle intéressant de voir
que les délégués aux transports aussi
parce qu'à partir du moment où vous
nommer un ministre en titre des
transports qui est à l'extérieur de
montréal ou québec
vous avez besoin de quelqu'un à montréal
ou à québec comme délégué aux transports
parce que c'est là qu'ils allaient plus
gros investissement minutes en matière
de transport naturel ministre
responsable de la région de la côte-nord
monsieur jonathan juliette
c'est lui qui sera responsable financier
de la côte nord monsieur julien oui élu
dans la circonscription dans une
circonscription à québec l'ancien bras
droit de régis labeaume jeu jonathan
julien déclare sous serment que je
remplirai les devoirs de ma charge de
membres du conseil exécutif avec
honnêteté et justice et que je ne ferai
connaître sans y être dûment autorisée
quoique ce soit dont j'aurais eu
connaissance dans l'exercice de ma
charge jeu jonathan julien déclare sous
serment que je remplirai les devoirs de
ma charge de ministre de l'énergie et
des ressources naturelles et de ministre
responsable de la région de la côte nord
avec on a été et justice les gens des
régions que bassin vont noter qu'il n'a
pas été nommé responsable de la région
de québec s'arrêter un peu particulier
parce qu'il s'est déjà brouillé avec
monsieur la banque donc vous le disiez
il s'arrêtait donc un peu particulière
pour lui de chicanes la wii c'était
c'est écrit dans ciel qui ne serai pas
le ministre responsable de la capitale
nationale il a été élu dans la
circonscription de charlesbourg et c'est
quand même une surprise je vous dirais
qu'il soit nommé à l'énergie et les
ressources naturelles
on l'avait pas vu venir je vous avoue
dans ce poste-là dans les rumeurs
d'accession au conseil des ministres on
entendait le nom de monsieur jugnet
circulé mais pas nécessairement à titre
de ministre de l'énergie et des
ressources naturelles non leur ai pas
vus aux affaires municipales parce
qu'ils étaient en brouille avec fréjus
la bombe
avait d'autres postes évidemment qu'ils
étaient dédiées à d'autres personnes
donc ils se retrouvent avec peut-être
l'épineux dossier rappelez vous du
projet éolien d'appuyer que la coalition
avenir québec et a dit qu'il annulerait
un projet que hydro-québec a signé avec
des communautés giro
je nadine giraud déclare socialement que
je remplir et les devoirs de ma charge
de membres du conseil exécutif avec
honnêteté et justice et que je ne ferai
connaître sans être dûment autorisée
quoi que ce soit dont j'aurais eu
connaissance dans l'exercice de ma
charge
je n'ai jean giraud déclaré sous serment
que je remplirai les devoirs de ma
charge de ministre des relations
internationales et de la francophonie
avec honnêteté et justice algéro est
d'origine haïtienne elle est née à saint
louis au missouri
voici une partie son enfance à gaspé et
demeures dans les laurentides depuis 30
ans sera responsable donc vous l'avez
entendu des relations internationales et
de la francophonie
oui elle est spécialisé en affaires et
en finance et en marketing parce qu'elle
a obtenu un diplôme d hec
c'est intéressant de voir que madame
giroux sera sévère aux relations
internationales
ça veut probablement dire que monsieur
legault veut donner une impulsion
économique de développement économique à
son ministère des relations
internationales qui avaient christine
st-pierre à cause d'eux
du parcours de madame st-pierre avait
plusieurs profils peut-être culturel il
y avait évidemment du développement
économique qui se faisait avec christine
st pierre
mais en choisissant quelqu'un qui vient
du milieu des affaires ou de la finance
on envoie un signal peut-être que le
ministère des relations internationales
servir à faire du démarchage économique
aux quatre coins du monde
ministre de l'immigration de la
diversité et de l'inclusion et leader
parlementaire
monsieur simon jolie barrette alors on
nous dit de plus comme le nouveau bras
droit dessus l'euro sinon j'allais un
bar est à 31 ans qui à l'épineux dossier
de l'immigration et qui en plus sera
l'hiver parlementaire pour l'équipe
gouvernementale le gros se tache pour
monsieur jaulin bas
je simon jaulin barrette déclare sous
serment que je remplirai les devoirs de
ma charge de membres du conseil exécutif
avec honnêteté et justice et que je ne
ferai connaître sans y être dûment
autorisée
quoi que ce soit dont j'aurais eu
connaissance dans l'exercice de ma
charge jeu simon jolie barrette déclare
sous serment que je remplirai les
devoirs de ma charge de ministre de
l'immigration de la diversité et de
l'inclusion avec honnêteté et justice
c'est un avocat genevois l'emploi de la
ville de montréal
je savais juridique donc immense tâche
nationale
il a en tout cas à court terme les plus
gros défi oui il en appelait son
assiette en fait c'est ça va être
difficile pour lui de concilier leader
parlementaire donc la gestion des
travaux parlementaires quels projets de
loi sont déposées à quel moment
comment on gère la façon de tenir des
commissions parlementaires par exemple
sur des projets de loi
en plus de s'occuper de l'immigration
avec le projet ambitieux de monsieur
legault de réduire de 50 milles à 40
mille le nombre d'immigrants de mieux
les intégrer donc ça veut aussi dire
s'assurer qu'on donne des cours de
français à des couacs on s'assure que
les ressources sont au rendez vous pour
mieux intégrer ces gens là et la laïcité
notamment l'interdiction de signes
religieux pour les personnes en
situation d'autorité c'est parce que
monsieur le goût de lui donne des petits
mots d'encouragement à la place qu el
hilal appelation d'assiette et peut-être
une petite déception parce qu'il n'est
pas indigné l'environnement et de la
lutte contre les changements climatiques
madame marie chantal chasser on a parlé
un peu plus tous ceux qui étaient avec
nous sommes chassés qui a battu
seulement rodin châteauguay
d'abord un coup de fer et 2 devient la
ministre de l'environnement là dessus et
le gouvernement s'en est pas caché ils
ont ils ont du travail à faire pour
redorer l'image de son nouveau
gouvernement là en environnement qu'il
était prêt même accepter les idées des
autres partis pourquoi pas on les tue
marie-chantal chasser déclare sous
serment que je remplirai les devoirs de
ma charge de membres du conseil exécutif
avec honnêteté et justice et que je ne
ferai connaître censé être dûment
autorisée
quoi que ce soit dont j'aurais eu
connaissance dans l'exercice de ma
change je marie chantal chasser déclare
sous serment que je remplirai les
devoirs de ma charge de ministre de
l'environnement et de la lutte contre
les changements climatiques avec
honnêteté et justice chaussée
a fondé une entreprise en aéronautique
quel est donc elle connaît bien la
technologie c'est une fable donc c'est
son premier mandat évidemment alors
voilà la nouvelle ministre de
l'environnement du québec et c'est une
surprise bien honnêtement parce que le
nom de madame chasser avait pas beaucoup
circulé on se demandait qui pourrait
être ministre de l'environnement les
noms de jean françois simard par exemple
qui a été ministre de l'environnement et
de l'eau au ministre délégué à
l'environnement et de l'eau et sous
bernard landry en une courte période et
qui avaient une expérience ministérielle
aurait pu occuper ce poste-là
donc c'est une certaine surprise
goodyear c'est un peu un talon d'achille
pour la coalition et québec
elle devra défendre la position de la la
caq sur l'environnement et sur la
défense de l'environnement savez le
ministre de l'environnement à
l'intérieur du conseil espace conte
empêcheurs de tourner en rond
qu'ils sont définis et de développement
économiques respecte l'environnement
dernier petit point n'ajustez pas votre
appareil il n'y a pas de traits d'union
entre marie et chantal dans son nom ce
n'est pas une erreur de frappe
c'est bel et bien comme ça qu'elle écrit
son ministre de la famille ministre
responsable de la région de l'outaouais
monsieur mathieu guy lacombe ancien
collègue un journaliste matthieu lacombe
qui devient les la famille
le journe outaouais ça déjà dire cela
kaki la région d'ottawa ça montre à quel
point la victoire elle que décisive
il ya trois semaines maintenant alors ce
jeu permet d' ennemi amie née sans doute
away sur le groupe en sport ça allait
arriver là il ya deux mois
[Applaudissements]
jeux matures lacombe déclare sous
serment que je rentre et les devoirs de
ma charge de membres du conseil exécutif
avec en été et justice et que je ne
ferai connaître sans être dûment
autorisée
quoi que ce soit dont j'aurais eu
connaissance dans l'exercice de ma
charge
un ami ça tombe on s'entend bien
même à deux garçons
parce qu'il veut parler à capucine jeu
mathieu lacombe déclaré sous serment que
je remplirai les devoirs de ma charge de
ministre de la famille
ça se sent petit garçon
justin
plutôt bon
là c'est une photo plus ancienne
mais je suppose un travail va paraître
exagéré quand ceux ci sont naturellement
l'aca temps de ministre responsable de
la région de l'outaouais avec honnêteté
et justice
je n'ai pas fait 31 ans je les barrettes
battu la combattre en temps un
changement de génération importants qui
se son père également aujourd'hui et le
lieutenant gouverneur est mise à
contribution
[Applaudissements]
ça l'humanisme la poste de
lieutenant-gouverneur l'histoire de mary
lacombe est très bon son histoire est
une histoire de choc exceptionnel petit
petit mathieu lacombe sept premiers de
famille d'accueil en famille d'accueil
il était ballotté d'une famille
d'accueil à l'autre et
à l'école secondaire moment donné il
avait trouvé une famille d'accueil une
famille d'accueil qui finalement lui
plaisait il est retourné chez lui le
midi pour manger son lunch et regarder
des émissions d'affaires publiques c'est
comme ça qu'il a pris goût au
journalisme il n'a pas eu disons une
enfance facile c'est au tour de thomas
du ciné art non alors c'est une belle
histoire
ce que vous venez de dire aussi l'oeil
raf il l'a eu facile comme bouger et
devient annulé un bravo les uns font
mouche je pense qu'ils se comparent
c'est du bonbon pour l'équipe de la
carte bien commun
image qu'il est comme image de renouveau
de fraîcheur
je
c'est passé un peu grossi ministre de la
culture et des communications ministre
responsable de la langue française
madame nathalie roy du tlm antarès
depuis 2012 nathalie roy était porte
parole en immigration l expérience on
parlait de son collègue juste avant être
carrasso lucide à la journaliste
haïtienne du canada
doit être comptable l'endroit jeu
nathalie roy déclare sous serment que je
remplirai les devoirs de ma charge de
membres du conseil exécutif avec
honnêteté et justice et que je ne ferai
connaître sans être dûment autorisée
quoi que ce soit dont j'aurais eu
connaissance dans l'exercice de ma
charge jeu nathalie roy déclare sous
serment que je remplirai les devoirs de
ma charge de ministre de la culture et
des communications et de ministre
responsable de la langue française avec
un été et justice difficile d'avoir la
plus content et satisfait en cochant
nathalie roy très fier d'avoir ce
ministère culture et communication
langue française et le gouvernement
précédent avait énoncé une politique
culturelle on verra ce qu'elle en fera
de cette politique culturelle s'il va
continuer à l'appliquer
petite anecdote vraiment très con viens
de le dire je très contente mais voilà
elle aura comme chef de cabinet m'a donc
maintenant gauthier qui est une ancienne
conseillère municipale à la ville de
montréal et qui était candidate de la
coalition du québec sur l'île de
montréal madame gauthier donc sur la
chef de cabinet de madame roy candidate
malheureuse dans le cas de madame
routier mais elle connaît très très bien
sait d'où aussi
et le milieu d'un cultive l'importance
de chef de cabinet on a parlé un peu
plus tôt cet été avec nous et c'est un
ciel
le ministre du travail de l'emploi et de
la solidarité sociale ministre
responsable de la région de la mauricie
monsieur jean boulet qui fera son entrée
au conseil des ministres
par contre ce n'était pas ce n'est pas
une surprise au sénat sion le voyait au
conseil d'une veste siglée un avocat des
trois rivières connu jeu jean boulet des
classes sous serment que je remplirai
les devoirs de ma charge de membres du
conseil exécutif avec honnêteté et
justice et que je ne ferai connaître
sans y être dûment autorisée
quoi que ce soit dont j'aurais eu
connaissance dans l'exercice de ma
charge
je joue en boulet déclenché sous serment
que je remplirai les devoirs de ma
charge de ministre du travail de
l'emploi et de la solidarité sociale et
ministre de la région responsable de la
région de la mauricie avec honnêteté et
justice donc monsieur boulet oui je vais
dire est un avocat avant de se lancer en
politique
les gens se posent la question est ce
que dans l'esprit de famille une croix
ça a l'air on a déjà vu ça
remarquez à l'assemblée nationale est
décidemment il sort david exactement les
frères johnson aussi à une certaine
époque monsieur goulet est un
spécialiste
ce que je comprends du droit du travail
donc naturel qu'il aboutisse au travail
on regroupe ensemble deux ministères
actuels le ministère de l'emploi et le
ministère du travail pour n'en faire
qu'un vous savez quand on doit passer de
d'une trentaine de ministères à 26 il
faut faire des défusions si on veut de
ministères alors il hérite de ses
responsabilités qui étaient jusqu'à
maintenant partagée par deux ministres
dans l'ancien gouvernement
[Applaudissements]
ministre des affaires municipales et de
l'habitation ministre responsable de la
région du saguenay-lac-saint-jean
madame landry la forêt partout au québec
le saguenay lac saint jean qui sera
représentée par madame la forêt de
gagner dans chicoutimi ce château fort
pic et non seignol de formation
directrice de chambre de la petite
enfance
je rendrai la forêt déclare sous serment
que je remplirai les devoirs de ma
charge de membres du conseil exécutif
avec honnêteté et justice et que je ne
ferai connaître sans être dûment
autorisée quoi que ce soit dont j'aurais
eu connaissance dans l'exercice de ma
charge
je rendrai la forêt déclare sous serment
que je remplirai les devoirs de ma
charge de ministre des affaires
municipales et de l'habitation et de
ministre responsable de la région du
saguenay-lac-saint-jean avec honnêteté
et justice
on a failli un représentant de la région
de chemillé latrines jean van hamme la
forêt aux affaires du patio non plus si
bas c'est ça aurait pointé après ne
savais pas ça oui et je vous avoue que
c'est une énorme surprise dans la mesure
où oui on pouvait s'attendre à ce qu'il
y ait un ministre qui viennent la région
du saguenay lac saint jean où la caq a
fait une percée mais donc madame la
forêt à paul le profil prédestiné à
devenir ministre des affaires
municipales et de l'habitation et là une
formation d'enseignante elle a été
enseignante elle est en ce moment
propriétaire d'une garderie d'une pré
maternelle alors donc c'est pas le
profil
traditionnel pour accéder à ce poste là
ça nous enlève aucune de ses qualités
mais peut-être qu'elle rend un
apprentissage rapide à faire des
dossiers des appels ministre ça c'est
certain
c'est compliqué les affaires municipales
et il ya des égos lecteurs clairement
monsieur vous voulez donner ligne
éthique le jus des pêcheries et de
l'alimentation ministre responsable de
la région du centre du québec monsieur
andré la montagne marie lamontagne de
petites gens sont à mi mandat
un homme d'affaires pilote d'hélicoptère
en charge d'un dossier extrêmement
important dont on parle pas assez
si je peux me permettre commentaires
l'agriculture je rendrai la montagne
déclare sous serment que je remplirai
les devoirs de ma charge de membres du
conseil exécutif avec honnêteté et
justice et que je ne ferai connaître
sans être dûment autorisée
quoique ce soit dont j'aurais eu la
connaissent connaissance dans l'exercice
de ma charge
je rendrai la montagne déclare sous
serment que je remplirai les devoirs de
ma charge de ministre de l'agriculture
des pêcheries et de l'alimentation et de
ministre responsable de la région centre
du québec avec honnêteté et justice
les gens vont apprendre à le connaître
que sur la montagne
je leur donne premier mandat en fait on
présente comme un trésor caché à la
coalition hargne à québec qu'on a pas
beaucoup vu
il a si je me rappelle bien accompagné
sa conjointe dans la maladie au cours
des dernières années il a été moins
présent à l'assemblée nationale mais on
le décrit comme quelqu'un de très
équilibré quelqu'un qui a une bonne tête
qui est rigoureux et qui peut mener les
dossiers il a été c'est un homme
d'affaires accompli notamment dans le
domaine de l'aviation
ça lui est arrivé si je me rappelle bien
d'arriver à des caucus en région en
hélicoptère alors ça vous donne une idée
un peu du personnage et il hérite donc
d'un dossier qui est important dans le
contexte du libre échange de l'accord de
libre échange en tête avec les états
unis est là
la percée qui est fait contre la gestion
du lait où il allait les concessions
encore été faite sur la gestion nov
le traité de libre échange avec l'europe
également ouvre une brèche dans la
gestion de l'offre
bref ce sont des dossiers délicats
ministre du tourisme madame caroline
peau
caroline proulx bien connu aussi des
gens parce qu'elle a été animé plusieurs
émissions d'affaires publiques à la
proue qui en est à son premier mandat
celle des recrues aussi la cas je
caroline proulx déclare sous serment que
je remplirai les devoirs de ma charge de
membres du conseil exécutif avec
honnêteté et justice et que je ne ferai
connaître sans y être dûment autorisée
quoique quoi que ce soit dont j'aurais
eu connaissance dans l'exercice de ma
charge jeu caroline proulx déclare sous
serment je remplir et les devoirs de ma
charge de ministre du tourisme avec
honnêteté et avec justice et lui ému
madame pour très contents de se
retrouver autour de la table du conseil
des ministres est historiquement où
traditionnellement le ministère du
tourisme et regarder un peu de haut par
les autres ministres en particulier ceux
qui ont des dossiers économiques
mais c'est un secteur de l'économie qui
est en pleine croissance et où il ya
d'énormes défis et donc ça prend
quelqu'un qui est capable de mettre en
valeur ce secteur de l'économie c'est un
ministère qui est un gros budget
nécessairement mr ministère qui doit
rassembler les gens pour pousser dans la
même direction pour amener notamment où
faire la promotion du tourisme au québec
et à mener différents à mener
différentes régions autour de la table
pour essayer de travailler en
convergence ou en synergie et les dans
l'optique de françois legault quelqu'un
qui est capable de très bien communiquer
ne m'ouvre appliquons à parler de cette
vision que monsieur legault à des
communications et de l'importance du
cadrage du message
dans quels cas permettez l'expression
dans ce milieu
lentement mais sûrement la photo de
famille des délais de transformation
salutaire bond au caire quand es-tu
chaud mais ce cas compte tenu de la
controverse qui a engendré en campagne
électorale son cinquième mandat
on parlait des gens de la première heure
de la dq ix dans notre exemple
évidemment incontournable dans la région
de québec qui était telle une très forte
majorité son cinquième mandat
il sera responsable la transformation du
numérique gouvernementale de jeu les
formes rigueur déclare sous serment que
je remplirai les devoirs de ma charge de
membres du conseil exécutif avec un été
et justice et que je ne ferai connaître
sans être dûment autorisée
quoi que ce soit dont j'aurais eu
connaissance dans l'exercice de ma
charge jeu éric caire déclaré sous
serment que je remplirai les devoirs de
ma charge de ministre délégué la
transformation numérique gouvernementale
avec honnêteté et justice et ce n'est
pas un ministre délégué l'année
on lui donne la tâche de mettre de
l'ordre dans la maison de ses achats
informatiques de ces contres
informatique qui valent des milliards
il est quand même rattachée selon ma
compréhension au conseil du trésor et en
effet il a fait c'est un de ces cheval
de bataille et à monsieur caire le
ménage dans les contrats informatiques
certains disaient qu'est après le
domaine de la construction c'est
l'endroit où il ya le plus de tentatives
d' influence de collusion pas
nécessairement de corruption mais qu'est
donc et c'est assez louche ce qui se
passe dans ce domaine là que le
gouvernement qui est souvent à faire
avec les mêmes sous traitants et que ses
sous traitants l'a parfois peuvent
abuser de la situation
c'est un fouillis bref c'est ce que ça
veut dire avec toutes les précautions
qu'il faut prendre
donc on a l'impression qu'ils mettent
qui fera le ménage là-dedans je rappelle
aussi que la corruption menée québec a
promis à internet haute vitesse partout
au québec au cours des prochaines années
l'on peut être serait il responsable de
ça et en effet malgré
les petits problèmes ou les problèmes
qu'il a eus pendant la campagne
électorale ils accèdent aux conseillers
liste ministre responsable des affaires
autochtones ministre responsable de la
région des laurentides madame sylvie
d'amour fou d'amour on a parlé un peu
plus tôt donc elle était pressentie pour
aboutir à ce poste et affaires
autochtones et petite mirabelle 12e
mandat jean ancien entrepreneur
donc madame d'amour aura sur dossier
toujours complexe et dénis plat des
relations avec le premier peuple avec
les autochtones jeu sylvie d'amour
déclare sous serment que je remplirai le
les devoirs de ma charge de membres du
conseil exécutif avait connectés et
justice et que je ne ferai connaître
sans y être dûment autorisée
quoi que ce soit dont j'aurais eu la
connaissance dans l'exercice de ma
charge
je suis lui d'amour déclare sous serment
que je remplirai les devoirs de ma
charge de ministre responsable des
affaires autochtones et de ministre
responsable de la région des laurentides
avec honnêteté et justice aujourd'hui
l'art antique attend beaucoup les gens
des laurentides qui attendent beaucoup
en 30 en termes de transport de fluidité
des transports et le net c'est le mot
tête à chaque matin et chaque soir sur
laquelle on a promis des choses aussi
pour toute la couronne nord de montréal
alors elle ne va pas que les le dossier
autochtone mais à devra faire le relais
de ces demandes pressantes des gens des
laurentides ce une région qui a triplé
de population depuis dix ans et qui est
incessant en plein boom démographique
alors il ya des particularités dans ces
régions là pour ce qui est des relations
avec les autochtones c'est parfois
quartiers difficiles
et ça prend du doigté jefferies calais
avait semble-t-il était très respectée
par les communautés autochtones
on verra comment madame d'amour pourra
entamer cette relation-là sera peut-être
difficile au début parce que on comprend
qu'elle parle peu ou mal l'anglais or
c'est une ombre qui peut être utilisé
avec les communautés autochtones
enfin on verra comment il se débrouille
assez forte
ministre des forêts de la faune et des
parcs ministre responsable de la région
de l'abitibi témiscamingue et de la
région du nord du québec monsieur pierre
dufour intéressant parce que d'une chute
du four a été candidat en parti libéral
du canada à l'epa avait été défait par
roméo saganash dans l'es12 montant est
maintenant à la cac
comportement
une entreprise familiale de plus beau
voyage devy responsable métier celui
d'un donneur
en honorant la mémoire
je déclare sous serment que je remplirai
les devoirs de ma charge de membres du
conseil exécutif avec honnêteté et
justice que je ne ferai connaître sans
être dûment autorisée
quoi que ce soit dont j'ai eu
connaissance dans l'exercice de ma
charge jeu et pierre dufour déclaré sous
serment que je vais remplir et les
devoirs de ma charge de ministre des
forêts de la faune et des parcs et d'un
ministre responsable de la région
d'abitibi témiscamingue et de la région
du nord du québec avec honnêteté et
justice donc choisi de didier ça c'est
moi c'est par à monsieur dufour qui sera
aussi l'une est responsable je le dire
de l'abitibi donc il y avait des
représentants de l'abitibi libéraux
péquistes autrefois que ce gendre ont
bien sûr c'est lui qui prend le relais
pour aller défendre les régions plus
éloignées comme l'abitibi puis la
question essentielle aussi des forêts
oui sans rien enlever à monsieur dufour
sa nomination concédé ministre illustre
peut-être la difficulté qui a eu
françois legault de faire accéder des
gens de toutes les régions à ce fameux
conseil des ministres il est député
d'abitibi-est on lui confie les forêts
la faune ailée par certains me disaient
qu on aurait pu facilement groupe et ça
avec les ressources naturelles par
exemple mais on a décidé d'en faire un
ministère à part et probablement qu'on a
décidé d'en faire un ministère à part
pour permettre justement à l'abitibi
d'être représenté au conseil des
ministres mesdames et messieurs et
c'était le nouveau conseil des ministres
du gouvernement du québec
alors voilà ils sont 26 trésor près de
fable dirigé par françois legault qui
vous avez remarqué fait l'accolade façon
très affectueuse à chacun d'entre eux
mission accomplie pour relevons
désormais si ces hommes et ces femmes
qui vont diriger le québec dès ce soir
d'ailleurs de 17 ans et un premier
conseil des ministres plus symbolique
qu'autre chose parce que pas tellement
de dossiers de projets de lois radié des
cadres pour montrer aux québécois qu'ils
sont à l'ouvragé au travail dès la
première journée le vin serment
conscient alors voilà la photo de sa
douce motion et martini
et ce qui est extraordinaire c'est que
ces 26 personnes n'ont pas d'expérience
ministérielle
la dernière fois qu'on avait vu ça
c'était celle là c'était au pas en 1976
n'y avait déjà plus de laisser la parole
on écoute le discours je prends des
ministres
[Applaudissements]
donc monsieur le lieutenant gouverneur
du québec
ce président l'assemblée nationale
mesdames messieurs les nouveaux
ministres mesdames messieurs les députés
mesdames messieurs les maires madame
messieurs les membres des communautés
autochtones
mesdames et messieurs les membres du
corps consulaire
le secrétaire général du gouvernement
ce secrétaire général de l'assemblée
nationale
et vous allez me permets de salut ma
mère de 89 ans simon
[Applaudissements]
ma mère de 89 ans qui m'a tout donné
mais aussi moments je veux saluer mes
deux soeurs hélène français je salue mes
deux fils xavier et victor ces voix qui
meurent n'inspirer mon épouse isabelle
sans qui tout cela serait pas possible
et il va me chicaner parce que je le dis
là m'avait interdit de dire son nom mais
je veux saluer mon fidèle compagnon est
là depuis le début de la caq sens qui
ont serais pas ici aujourd'hui
martin koskinen merci
donc distingués invités mesdames
messieurs cette journée très spéciale
très spécial pour moi
spécial certains pour plusieurs aux
personnes je vois dans cette salle
beaucoup de sourires je vois surtout un
grand sentiment de fierté d'avoir marqué
l'histoire du québec
ensemble je vous présente aujourd'hui un
conseil des ministres qui lui aussi est
très spécial à plusieurs égards d'abord
c'est un conseil des ministres paritaire
un conseil donc formé à 50% de femmes
des femmes de grande qualité de grande
compétence
un conseil qui reflète cette valeur
fondamentale au québec l'égalité entre
les hommes et les femmes mesdames merci
d'avoir accepté ces grandes
responsabilités
merci beaucoup
[Applaudissements]
cette équipe aussi est spécial par le
nombre de ministres qui n'ont jamais été
ministre
en fait sauf marguerite et moi tous les
mails istres occupe cette fonction pour
la première fois
et je vais vous dire que je vois pas ça
comme un désavantage au contraire
gouvernement du québec a besoin de
renouveau gouvernement du québec a
besoin de visages 9 qui vont jeter un
regard neuf et vous apporter ensemble un
immense bagage d'expérience de
compétence que vous avez acquis ailleurs
dans la société
je vous demande je vous demande de
mettre cette expérience cette compétence
au service des québécois au service du
changement
l'autre côté spéciale de ce conseil des
ministres c'est le nombre important de
ministres qui ont une expérience
d'entrepreneur ou de gestionnaire
certains analystes l'ont déjà ailleurs
remarqué et ça tombe bien parce que
l'argent qui nous est confié pour les
québécois peut et doit être gérée de
façon encore plus efficace avec rigueur
est pareil à geler dit souvent
l'acceptent pas que le québec soit moins
riche que le reste du canada
l'économie du québec peut faire mieux et
ça tombe bien on a une équipe économique
de rêve
[Applaudissements]
et quand je parle d'une équipe
économique de rêve je parle bien sûr des
finances d'économies mais je parle aussi
l'éducation d'agriculture d'énergie de
forêt relation canadienne relations
internationales tourisme emploi énergie
culture immigration développement
régional transport affaires autochtones
environnement je vous demande à tout le
monde de mettre vos compétences au
service de l'économie du québec pour
enrichir tous des québécois dans toutes
les régions
les priorités de notre gouvernement sont
très claires elle se résume en trois
mots éducation économie santé en
éducation
où est mon jean françois isabelle notre
engagement le plus important c'est de
s'assurer que chaque enfant québécois
puissent aller au bout de son potentiel
et
cette grande et noble ambition elle
passe par le dépistage précoce des
enfants qui ont des difficultés
d'apprentissage dans la création des
maternelles quatre ans par la joute
professionnelle dans nos écoles par
l'appui à nos enseignants par la
valorisation de leur profession par la
rénovation de nos écoles si on doit
légué une chose une seule chose au
québec c'est de donner à chacun de nos
enfants la possibilité d'aller au bout
de son potentiel
en économie on a promis pendant la
campagne électorale
on a pris l'engagement de remettre de
l'argent dans le portefeuille des
québécois en particulier celui des
familles mais aussi celui des retraités
qui ont de faibles revenus
eric préparatoires dans les prochaines
heures
on va se mettre au travail pour vous
annoncer des bonnes nouvelles au cours
des prochaines semaines
[Applaudissements]
on a pris l'engagement aussi d'augmenter
le niveau de richesse du québec en
augmentant les investissements les
entreprises en augmentant en
diversifiant nos exportations
j'ai commencé ce travail la semaine
dernière à l'occasion du sommet de la
francophonie en multipliant les
rencontres avec des chefs d'état et j'ai
insisté sur notre volonté sur la volonté
de notre nouveau gouvernement
d'augmenter concrètement nos
exportations
nos échanges commerciaux diversifier nos
marchés on veut travailler on a une
équipe de rêve pour y arriver en santé
quel trio extraordinaire notre mission
première consiste que lorsqu'un
québécois est malade il puisse voir
rapidement un médecin ou une infirmière
sans devoir engorger les urgences on
devra aussi traiter nos aînés en perte
d'autonomie avec toute la dignité qu'ils
méritent
on devra aussi pour ce qu'il m'arrivait
nommait mieux aider les parents
d'enfants handicapés
on devra mieux soutenir les projets d'un
ancien engage encore aujourd'hui
donc cessons nos grandes priorités
auxquelles je vais ajouter une sincère
préoccupation pour les défis
environnementaux
on aura bien oui
on a bien reçu le message la population
pendant la campagne on doit en faire
plus pour lutter contre le réchauffement
climatique
on va y travailler chantal à notre façon
de façon pragmatique en obtenant des
résultats
le non engagement important qu'on a pris
c'est celui de déposer dans la première
année de notre mandat un projet de
réforme du mode de scrutin
cette promesse va être que nous
on devra aussi préserver l'avenir en
gérant les finances publiques de façon
rigoureuse en éliminant le gaspillage en
donnant des services de façon efficace
devra aussi se montrer exemplaire en
matière d'intégrité et on devra assumer
notre responsabilité de fiduciaire de
cette longue histoire de nation de
langue française en amérique
donc notre gouvernement fera la
promotion de notre langue commune de
notre culture de nos valeurs notre
gouvernement aussi été élu avec un
mandat clair sur la laïcité on s'est
engagé à interdire le port de signes
religieux pour les employés de l'état en
position d'autorité
on va respecter nos engagements
[Applaudissements]
respectueux quant à communauté
anglophone historique est à cet égard il
me fait plaisir d'annoncer la nomination
de christophe ski
christopher dit même rester feu et le
député de sainte rose à laval et
l'adjoint parlementaire le premier
ministre il sera responsable du dossier
des relations avec les québécois
anglophones
on voit aussi gouverner en prenant
compte là venez des membres des
premières nations
j'ai l'intention je pense qu'il a déjà
fait du lait d'avoir des rencontres dans
les prochains jours les prochaines
semaines je veux établir avec vous des
relations respectueuses
je vous demande maintenant mesdames
messieurs les ministres de gouverner
dans un esprit de proximité d'humanité
et d'ouverture et pour moi c'est trois
points
[Applaudissements]
ces trois notions proximité humanité
ouvertures sont fondamentales pour moi
je veux qu'elle devienne la marque de
commerce de notre gouvernement
oui on a remporté une victoire éclatante
avec une majorité de 74 sièges
ça nous confère une marge de manoeuvre
une grande marge de manoeuvre
on pourrait tenter de gouverner comme
bon nous semble
mais au contraire vous demande de
gouverner en obtenant l'adhésion du plus
grand nombre
d'abord l'adhésion des membres de la
fonction publique
oui on peut avoir un gouvernement qui
est plus efficace plus sensible plus
agile et je convaincu d'ailleurs que la
majorité des fonctionnaires des
enseignants du personnel de la santé des
membres du secteur public sont d'accord
pour offrir des services plus efficaces
aux québécois donc votre premier défi
mais là messieurs les ministres c'est
que les membres de la fonction publique
adhèrent à nos changements faudra aussi
avoir l'adhésion à nos changements de la
plus grande partie de la population on
fera jamais l'unanimité
d'ailleurs y est hors de question de
reculer devant des groupes de pression
ou devant les secousses les premières
petites secousses mais pour changer ce
qui fonctionne pas
pour changer j'ai appris ça en affaires
c'est vrai du côté public pour changer
ce qui fonctionne pas suis pas décréter
faut aller chercher l'adhésion du
maximum de personnes et je veux vous
dire quand on a les québécois derrière
nous rien n'est possible
aujourd'hui on forme pas le gouvernement
de la cac
aujourd'hui on forme le gouvernement des
québécois de tous les québécois peu
importe l'allégeance politique
on va travailler pour tous les québécois
et je tiens à rassurer les gens de la
gaspésie de la côte nord et de l'ouest
de montréal
on ne vous oubliera pas en forme
aussi voit gouvernement
donc la proximité c'est essentiel on
doit rester proche des préoccupations
des québécois
je vous demande de sortir de vos bureaux
d'aller sur le terrain rencontrer
d'échanger que les citoyens avec les
entrepreneurs les enseignants les
médecins des infirmières et préposés les
malades des enfants et c'est mon
intention aussi comme premier ministre
de demeurer en contact avec les
québécois dans toutes les régions du
québec
donc je vous demande de faire la même
chose de sortie d'écouter notre
gouvernement doit être un gouvernement
proche du monde
bien sûr le gouvernement et les membres
de la fonction publique doivent faire
respecter les lois et les règles mais on
doit changer des habitudes et des
attitudes l'appareil public doit exercer
son bon sens et son humanité
on a vu trop souvent des décisions
tatillonne se transformer en petite
tragédie parce qu'on avait évacué le bon
sens et l'humanité je vous demande de
travailler en vous servant de votre bon
sens et votre humanité auprès des
québécois
je termine en m'adressant aux québécois
ce gouvernement c'est votre gouvernement
ce conseil des ministres il est à votre
service
on va travailler de toutes nos forces
avec toute notre cas pour vous offre
mais on va avoir besoin de vous
si on est des millions à pousser dans la
même direction
tout est passé oui
je termine en vous disant j'aime les
québécois et pour répondre à un homme
qui m'ont inspiré toute ma vie j'ai
lèvres conviction profonde que oui on
forme quelque chose comme un grand
peuple merci
premier discours du premier ministre en
exercice françois legault qui s'y est la
toute fin rené lévesque qui disaient oui
j'ai le sentiment qu'on fait quelque
chose comme un grand peuple
françois legault qui a lancé un appel à
six ministres un rappel d'une certaine
façon proximité avec les gens qui nous
ont élus et même ceux qui ont provoqué
pour une proximité humanité ouverture du
trop souvent le gouvernement la grosse
machine du gouvernement on oublie
quelque chose comme le bon sens le bon
sens keira la vie impossible à certaines
personnes quittent les décrochements
pour les citoyens françois legault dont
qui lance un appel à cette équipe que
vous voyez et on souligne à part lui et
marguerite blais aucune de ces personnes
aucun les 25 autres ministres n'a de
l'expérience ministérielle
donc c'est un énorme vent de renouveau
qui souffle sur l'appareil
gouvernemental québécois pour tous plus
haut niveau à votre conseil des
ministres complètement transformé réunit
également est complètement paritaire
monsieur legault qui a explosé aussi
clairement ses priorités qu'on connaît
bien
éducation économie santé en économie il
a dit que d'ici quelques semaines eric
en parlant d' eric girard lumineuse et
finances elle est arrivée avec des
bonnes nouvelles
ça ça veut dire de l'argent pas les
poches des québécois selick c'était la
promesse en campagne électorale
en santé il a rappelé que l'important
c'était que les québécois malades
puissent être soignés et une évidente
personnes âgées
ce qui nous vaut environnement ils ont
entendu les québécois en campagne
électorale il faut en faire plus il faut
qu'on en développe plus au sein de notre
parti de notre gouvernement
madame chassé qui la nouvelle ministre
de l'environnement or cet âge là sur la
laïcité martin biron très très clairs
comme appelle également pas question de
reculer notre mandat était clair abolir
les signes religieux pour les personnes
en autorité
on verra et monsieur jolie barrette
donnera des entrevues je le recevrai
plus tard au téléjournal on verra est ce
que ça veut dire que pour les
enseignants par exemple c'est vraiment
clair comme ça il n'y aura pas de recul
possible où on parle des fameux
consensus
bouchard taylor avec juge quinzaine
prison policiers cetera donc laïcité et
dernier appel
dernier élément qu'il a ajouté les
anglophones on vous oublie pas même si
on n'a aucun député dans l'oise à
montréal et les autochtones
il tend la main à vraiment premier
discours où il se veut rassembleur et
surtout martin il
vraiment envoyer le message aux
québécois qui prend rien pour acquis que
ce gouvernement là ne doit pas partir en
flèche vers les tours de québec pu
oublier le monde oublie le peuple oui
c'est un discours que je dirais très
simple les priorités sont de base
elles rejoignent les gens il a été élu
sur la question du changement le on dit
qu'en politique le plus grand danger qui
guette les politiciens c'est l'arrogance
et souvent ça vient avec l'usure du
pouvoir et c'est un peu là dessus que
sur ce clou là que monsieur legault a
tapé en disant je veux que vous sortiez
de chez vous que vous soyez proche de
vos citoyens
que vous soyez à l'écouté de ce qu'ils
ont à dire et c'est un peu là dessus
qu'il s'est beaucoup là dessus qu'il a
été élu et il veut rester très proche de
sa base électorale alors ses priorités
elle son sein un plan éducation économie
santé que l'on exige en soulignant il
dit depuis quelques semaines on peut
s'attendre à mieux gérer quand je
prépare une mise à jour sans doute
d'ailleurs il ya plusieurs de ses
promesses électorales qui va il va
certainement la présenter monsieur
legault va vouloir rapidement envoyer le
signal sa phrase qu'il a martelé depuis
des années c'est remettre de l'argent
dans les poches des québécois alors il
va vouloir marquer le coup ils marquent
le coup aujourd'hui en respectant sa
promesse sur la parité de son cabinet la
prochaine étape sera de avec des mesures
économiques fortes en santé
c'est tout ça et le dire vous êtes
malade vous devriez avoir accès à un
médecin
on verra comment il sera capable
d'appliquer cette mesure là en éducation
aussi c'est tout simple mais on sait que
c'est un peu plus c'est l'aider avec
gironde atlantique
ouais c'est ça le détail elle est le
diable est dans les détails que vous
avez compris de la laïcité on a eu
l'impression de manquer c'était vraiment
très nette
ecoutez-le on reculera pas l'action il a
beaucoup parlé junnila surtout parlé du
consensus de mouchan tel un saint
vraiment insister sur la question des
enseignants je vous rappelle que la
proposition initiale de la cac
c'est d'interdire le port des signes
religieux pour les personnes en pulsions
coercitive de l'état saisir je juge
procureur de la couronne policiers et la
caq ajoute les et les enseignants ce qui
n'est pas nécessairement le cas des
autres groupes parlementaires
on pense que le compromis pourrait
certainement se faire sur ce point là
c'est simon jo les barrettes qui aura le
mandat de déposer ce premier
projet de loi on s'attend est-ce que
la chambre les travaux parlementaires ne
dure que deux semaines ou trois semaines
d'ici noël
peut-être que monsieur jaulin barrette
et frais a déposé ce projet douala et
qui pourra commencer à être étudiés
rapidement après les faits on verra
comment les différents groupes
parlementaires vont se positionner
cela dit je voudrais que les libéraux
ont déjà insisté pour dire qu'il tenait
ça me touche si on ferme rester là
martin ça me titille là il ya du sang
qui sort de ce petit groupe on va aller
voir si on peut entendre la conversation
c'est
je parlais pas les consignes
on le voit on se prépare d'ailleurs on
se met en place pour la photo de famille
alors les gens se place depuis un ordre
évidemment martin devient bien établi
pour cette photo de famille et ce qui
marquera c'est pas la première fois mais
la deuxième fois au québec
c'est vraiment un gouvernement d'abord
je lui dis à par le gault et madame
blais ailleurs personne que d'expérience
ministérielle ça c'est très très très
très longtemps qu'on n'avait pas vu ça
faut remonter à rené lévesque en 76
mais déjà il y en avait plus qu avait
l'expérience ministérielle à l'époque du
premier conseil des listes de rené
lévesque qui là qu'il a d'ailleurs cité
à revoilà la sas et la mosaïque
donc voici les 13 hommes et des 13
femmes qui vont gouverner le québec au
cours des prochaines années des quatre
prochaines années
allawi frappant donc hommes et femmes ça
on a respecté et changement de
génération et un regard neuf forcément
sur les dons aussi plus qu'ils ont peu
d'expérience ministérielle à ce qu est
ce qui m'a frappé de ce cabinet c'est
sur la région de montréal et de laval je
vous dirais qu'il ya peut-être une
faiblesse dans le
le ce cabinet là en ce sens qu' il n'y a
que seul ministre dans cette région là
et c'est chantal rouleau et ce n'est pas
un ministre en titre
on aurait pu s'attendre à ce que les
portefeuilles beaucoup plus important
dans ses représentations pour la région
de montréal et même à laval
monsieur legault n'a réussi qu'à faire
élire qu'un seul député qui christopher
ce kit qui n'a pas été retenu pour ce
cabinet donc les plus importantes la
plus importante
une ville du québec et si que la
deuxième municipalité en importance au
québec sont non aucun ministre
responsable en titre quoique madame
rouleau sera un ministre responsable de
la métropole mais son poste est un poste
de ministre délégué dont actuellement ya
pas de poids lourds sur l'île tout à
vrai dire clairement il n'y a pas deux
poids lourds sur l'île et ça ça fait
longtemps qu'on n'a pas vu ça non plus
et il n'y a pas deux poids lourds à
laval non plus alors la dynamique vous
va s'exercer autres membres lavez les
dossiers montréalais de la ville de
montréal et le gouvernement legault
monsieur legault
même s'il est député de l'assomption
connaît bien montréal connaît bien la
réalité montréalaise y habitent
alors voilà la photo de famille d'abord
et pourtant
[Applaudissements]
et moi ce qui me frappe
alex vous êtes à l'extérieur ce qui m'a
frappé on vient
et un cours
et c'est intéressant parce que des gens
qui disaient patrice houssou n'est que
les plans b de la création du québec
sont mes meilleurs que les plans c'était
le cas aussi de jeunes bien guilbaud
vous souvenez lors de la partielle dans
louis hébert qui avait remplacé le
candidat de la coalition québec
sauvageau qui avait eu des problèmes
dans les relations travail lorsqu'il
était dans une banque dont luz avait été
remplacé et c'est là pour la coalition
bois québec que le vent tournait donc
évidemment le voyez que tous les gens
qui attendent les médias bleus si je
suis bon j'ai justement qu'on attendait
entre autres me suis je les renvoie les
coutures aux mains du christ que vous
fassiez discuter vous devez agir très
rapidement qu'on mette ça derrière vous
rapidement dangereux trop dans son
discours inaugural le premier ministre
est clairement un trick souhaitait que
le dossier de la laïcité se règle
rapidement
c'est un engagement que nous avons fait
que nous allons respecter les personnes
en situation d'autorité
avec un pouvoir de coercition ne porte
pas de signes religieux alors mené à
bien
les prochains mois soyez assurés que
aujourd'hui on va se mettre au travail
on va faire en sorte de consulter
l'ensemble du conseil des ministres le
caucus on va profiter la société
légalement mais on va
messieurs ministre dauphine est il pas
dans l'île
c'est la laïcité concerne pas uniquement
les immigrants ça se sent pas un
amalgame un peu et sont deux dossiers
complètement distincts le premier
ministre confié trois dossiers celui de
leader parlementaire super maman
celui de ministre l'immigration et celui
du dossier de la laïcité dont deux sans
trois dit aussi que je fais séparément
et effectivement il n'y a aucun lien
entre la laïcité l'immigration c'est une
marque de confiance que le premier
ministre fait de ce qu'on veut me
confier trois dossiers comme ceux
trois importantes aussi et je compte
bien mater la tâche pour les hommes
c'est quoi la perception
c'est tout à fait distincts les dossiers
d'immigration et de laïcité les dossiers
de l'ida ce sont des dossiers d
au même titre que plusieurs de mes
collègues ont plusieurs
aussi connexes alors chacun des dossiers
puis séparément dans l'action globale
drame
personnellement deux dernières tenter
par ce dossier là ce qui selon ses
dreads il est resté associé à l'achat
comment
sa carrière par la suite
man de la caq obtenu un appui massif des
québécois pour réaliser
gageons qu'elles ont engagées notamment
c'est dans ce sens
et avec l'appui de la population de
québec avec l'appui des collègues
parlementaires et avec l'appui de mômes
les embryons l'actuaire dans noël
disons que c'est votre question il est
très prématuré
on
on vient à peine
cinq minutes que je viens d'être
assermenté on comprendrait que je vais
rencontrer
les fonctionnaires du ministère on va
le temps de faire les choses d'une façon
ordonnée
de prendre
c'est une réponse j'avais beaucoup
attendent aujourd'hui et c'est de bonne
guerre éliminer ce gène assermentés
franchement bonnardel de la victime
s'étaient mis eux aussi en serbie gyan
mais on a vu sa ligne transport sont
faits année après année autant pour les
pompiers pour les infrastructures
routières donc on va se mettre au
travail en étant dirais que je vous
demandais justement ce ton histoire qui
dit si le ministre des transports on dit
que c'est soit un mange ministre ça ne
fait pas notre peau du dos après 11 ans
dit politique dans l'opposition je vous
dirais que j'entreprends ce défi avec
beaucoup d'enthousiasmé demain matin
donc on va rencontrer mon équipe le
sous-ministre la chute mais ministre
délégué chantal rouleau qui m'épaule à
montréal là dessus on se met en boule ou
dès la semaine prochaine puis on voit
livré la marchandise a pour priorité bah
ça aurait nécessairement prolongement
sur m à montréal
il va avoir le troisième vient à québec
il ya d'innombrables routes partout au
québec le qui ont besoin d'amour les
infractions d'excès de l'entretien on le
sait depuis tant d'années donc on va se
mettre au boulot résidents parlement
passablement comprend alors pas du tout
j'ai eu quatre années de parole comme
les dames et on se met au boulot comme
2010 et transport cette occasion merci
alors oui avec 1000 et des transports il
manquera pas de dossiers chauds bien
évidemment ce troisième vient à québec
ils se sont engagés à ce que la
construction soit commencée en quoi que
ce soit quand kate d'ici 4 à
c'est pas rien et il va falloir qu'ils
discutent avec le maire régis labeaume
s'est excusé pour aller crucifier le
reste alors va-t-il minutes la famille
non mérité en place et je vais établir
les miennes
efforts mais bien à s'étendre
c'est un destin qui n'aurait pas été
normal que le dossier de laïcité de la
neutralité religieuse soit dans les
mains de la ministre une injustice qui
par essence minutes comme laminé zène
justice - l'occurrence je serai là de
toute façon je serai là où je fais
partie du conseil du xive je fais partie
de la des bois qui vont être autour de
la tama là je pense qu'on a le premier
ministre très bien choisi les différents
porteurs de portefeuille demande pour
mener à bien les dossiers et j'ai
totalement confiance à mon collègue
lendemain de réformer le mode de scrutin
les premiers estiot démocratie comme il
y en avait à les précédents
gouvernements à qui serviront dans le
style est en dessous sous l'égide de la
de la justice donc répondait à des
élections démocratiques vont être de ma
responsabilité
l'accès à l'information également
d'autres manquent pas ces procédés pour
la réforme du mode de scrutin est ce que
vous aimeriez faire des consultations
avant
examiné différents modèles vous allez me
permettre de me faire une taille mais
effectivement l'objectif est de réformer
d'avoir une proportionnelle donc mettons
lot aujourd'hui le diable est dans les
détails alors effectivement vaut
consulter en droit de quelle façon il
est mieux de le faire
on s'assurer qu'ils aient peur de pertes
mais simplement des gains pour la
société dans cette mission
sonia label qui n'a pas le dossier de la
laïcité mais minés même si elle est
ministre de la justice pendant qu on
voit là qui sont pas contacté une
mi-temps pété un plomb du riche à 5 les
pouvoirs des choix très complexe et g
dalphond beaucoup d'admiration pour le
communisme que pour ceux qui sont le
chasseur avait été présenté comme un
cancer des poumons à quoi s en tenir
québec il y avait une grosse pression
qui était mis sur vous convient pas vu
beaucoup durant la campagne ont plus et
l'on vous voit pas conseil des ministres
est-ce que vous senti contente d'une
tacite
on m'a vu à plusieurs reprises durant la
campagne notamment dans les laurentides
et notamment dans son parler
d'efficacité de l'état donc aux
contraintes satan dit est ce que ça te
dit quelque chose sur un recentrage du
parti parce que vous auriez d'associer
tous à la droite à l'endroit du parti
est-ce que ça avec un choix politique
non je pense à quoi s'en tenir qu'à
défendre vraiment des gens qui ont
déconcentré forte de tous les horizons
grande compétence une grande expérience
et on a vu le premier ministre a appelé
les gens du cabinet en est cette
expérience ses compétences et la
fonction au service des citoyens du
québec
donc évidemment pour moi c'est pas du
tout un enjeu qui a été construit vous
allez pouvoir faire vous pensez comme
ministre plutôt comme député pendant les
prochains mois des prochaines années
auparavant la jouerie chassaing qui bon
joueur dit écoutez c'est comme ça je
félicite ceux qui ont été appelés moi je
n'ai pas été évidemment à l'est qui a je
passais avec moi tant mieux en 1 re sans
alexis yahia recentrage qu'on a voulu
faire du côté de la caq puis on
préférerait peut-être pas donné l'image
monsieur chasse un qui a des positions
quand même assez marquées qui a été
historiquement contre la gestion de
l'offre
etc etc etc alors avec ce je vais
terminer avec vous
sébastien prend le relais avec les
mordus dans quelques secondes nouveau
gouvernement totalement frais ou du veau
des des ministres qui n'ont pas
d'expérience aucun regard neuf sur plein
de dossiers mais là on le sent le
premier dossier s'investissement jaulin
barrette la laïcité
ils veulent mettre ça derrière eux le
plus vite possible pour arriver
ouvrez entre guillemets priorité de ce
gouvernement
on va devoir beaucoup monsieur simon
j'en ai marre est parce que la laïcité
goody et l'immigration aussi avec les
propositions phares qu'on connaît
réduction des seuils d'immigration
baisse des valeurs test de français
rapatriés déploie aussi d'ottawa donc
nécessairement évoque une très grande
place ici à l'assemblée nationale dans
les prochains mois alex persie beaucoup
je remercie tous mes camarades du bureau
de québec pour cette émission spéciale
sébastien bovet prend le relais je vous
retrouve mois 2 à 17 heures on aura
entre autres monsieur genève arrête en
entrevue on va lui poser des questions
sur la laïcité sur les autres dossiers
en a mais cannes mais les as en titre
avec nous au téléjournal plus tard
également merci à toute l'équipe
on se retrouve dans moins d'une heure
[Musique]